good morning everyone welcome to the
baby district council planning committee
i will ask the government's officer to
read out the domestic arrangements and
the fire regulation clarity with mr
train
thank you chair
please ensure that you maintain social
distancing from all other persons whilst
in the chamber and in communal areas
please ensure that you wear a face
covering at all times unless you are
sitting down or if you're exempt from
doing so and that you use the hand
sanitizer and wipes provided
please ensure that the microphones are
turned off when not in use
please do not interrupt other speakers
or hold separate conversations whilst
others are speaking
if you are attending the meeting to
speak and persistently interrupt the
meeting you may be asked to leave
please ensure that your mobile phones on
silent or switched off
we will be using the e-voting for this
meeting on the modern gov app so please
could members make sure they are logged
in and ready to use the app
if you hear the fire alarm leave the
building immediately via a fire exit and
make your way to the assembly point
ipswich town football grounds
follow the signs directing you to the
fire exits at each end of the floor
do not enter the atrium ground floor
area and walkways if you are in the
atrium at the timing alarm follow the
signs to the nearest fire exit
use the stairs not the lifts do not
re-enter the building until it is safe
to do so
i would like to remind everyone present
that this meeting will be broadcast live
to the internet and will be capable of
repeated viewing the whole of the
melding
sorry meeting will be recorded except
where there are confidential or exempt
items
if you make a representation to the
meeting you will be deemed by the
council to have consented to being
recorded by entering this meeting as a
speaker you will also consent into being
recorded by the council
and to the possible use of those sound
recordings for webcasting and or
training purposes the council members of
the public and the press may record film
photograph or broadcast this meeting
when the public and the press are not
lawfully excluded
thank you chair
can you hear me now you hear all the
rest of it fine
we have
luke barber and mag
matt hollis from suffolk country country
we have two ward members present
um apologies for absence and
substitutions
chair we have apologies for absence from
councillor allison owen thank you
receive decorations for cuny and
opportunity interest by members are
there any to declare
no
ah
country
excuse me non-pecuniary interest in item
i can find the number
amongst all these pages of papers
dc 2004 615.
thank you
do you have any others
if not we'll move on
confirmation of the minutes of the
meeting held on the 14th of july have
you all had a copy and read them
are there any points regarding the
accuracy of the minutes
nope
in that case could i have a proposal
please counselors
secondary please
answer osbourne
now conduct the electronic vote
mr chair
members if you go to the plus sign and
the top right hand corner of your app
and select attendance and voting
this vote is now in progress
thank you chair that's ten votes
we love apologies eleven votes for
that's unanimous
thank you
no it's sorry that's my mistakes ten
votes forward
one apology yes
to receive notifications and petitions
in accordance with the council petition
scheme
let me see jeff i received
psych inspections i understand there is
a request for a site inspection
and rose are you going to
present
the details
good morning everyone a site visit has
been requested for this application at
irwin hall farm
the application is for the conversion
repair and extension of existing farm
buildings to form five dwellings
the erection of a garage
demolition of buildings which include
the existing dutch barn and metal cloud
barn and the erection of two new
dwellings the provision of a new
vehicular access to the street and
associated lands
landscaping
so this is the site here
the site visit has been requested on the
ground said it is
a controversial
controversial application
within close proximity of the grade two
listed ellerton hall here
and it's grade one listed gate house
and also involves conversion of historic
farmstead buildings
on the site here
here here and here
just for a bit of context this is a site
here
and this is the village
of shortly
just take you through some of the photos
that i've gathered at this stage um
this is photo from the roadside showing
the barns to be
demolished
again a picture from the road to the
side showing plants to be demolished
this is a photo from within the site and
you can see the metal clad barn on the
side there to be demolished
this is a picture from the roadside
showing the historic farmstead buildings
and the historic wall along the frontage
this is a
photo from within the site and it shows
a portion of the historic farmstead
buildings and also buildings to be
demolished
this is a photo from where the proposed
access would come in and you can see the
metal clad
barn there and the dutch barn at the
front
and this is the great unlisted gate
house and you can see that here and this
is the site in question here with the
historic
farmstead buildings there and there in
the wall
thank you
are there any questions from members
with the officer councilman
you mr chairman just a quick question
where's the built-up area boundary
relative to the site
it is outside of the built-up area
boundary the nearest village is is
shortly where i showed you on the maps
there
how's the baron
uh presumably those barns have a certain
amount of pd rights and the only thing
that would query there is the fact it's
near the listed building is that correct
uh yes and it's also within the aomb
landscape as well which affects the pd
rights it does right okay thanks
um
i propose that we don't go over on the
site visit i think the photographs are
pretty clear
but uh uh who actually requested the
site visit
councillor derek davis the ward member
what is the recommendation of offices of
this fight at the moment
at this stage we are looking to
recommend approval approval
um i can't see that we need to have a
site visit any sector for that
thanks to beer you're in a second you
want to say anything um now i think it's
all been said
any other comments before we vote on
that
so
council of usb
uh yes it's um due to it being
controversial in the um
in the locality and
potential impacts to heritage assets
a b landscape and
highways
access is a concern as well
okay
any other comments
excuse me no thank you chair
um
i'm not sure that we've got the picture
of the adjacent erwitton hall
well because that is next door to it it
is next door
unfortunately because because of um
covert implications i haven't been able
to go onto the site to get those photos
yeah i'm familiar with the site
okay
thank you yeah i just people need to
know how it is very adjacent to uh
thank you
thank you any other thanks raheem
mr chairman in view of the um
controversial matrix uh i agree with the
council of barrett and uh
councillor beer that we don't i don't
think we need a site visit but will this
application be coming before the
committee because i think it's a little
bit uh
dubious as they recommend the officers
are recommending approval
chairman just just to clarify two things
uh yes the intention is to report this
application to committee as
controversial at present point in time
but obviously until we've published the
agenda the recommendation is not
formalised so
at the moment we are our direction of
travel is towards an approval but uh
that's what we can say thank you
um could we ask the
officer if you could get some more
photographs
i think if with the addition of a two or
three extra photographs that you can
probably get now because of
covert restrictions being eased i think
that probably would save us i don't
think the presentation as it is is
sufficient for us to get the
the feel towards the controversial
nature of it
happy to go and collect more photos at
snow problem
thank you
if that's the case then we have
a proposal can we
have a vote
thank you chair
members
vote reads our site visits shall not be
undertaken in respective application
number dc2003083
that vote
should now be showing in progress
[Music]
shall not be
undertaken before
must be the way it was worded by the
proposal
thank you members chair that's six votes
four and four gets against therefore a
site visit will not be undertaken thank
you
thank you very much
now
move on to item six schedule of planning
applications
the discussion today for approval or
refusal um
may i just point out to you that the
first one dc 2101460
is a discharge of condition not a
planning application
[Applause]
just on the
papers we have it's um
i think we need to just clarify who is
the ward member for this because um
it clearly stays here sudbury north west
and if that is sudbury northwest
uh obviously southerly northwest members
have five minutes if any one other
member once said it's three minutes and
i think we just need to make it clear
that who is the board member
because i think there might be some
members that think they're more members
this is on page 11.
we have to ask the government officer
that question
as i understand it it is councillors
mayberry and arty well it doesn't say it
on the page i know
so i think clarification is required for
clarification um there are two
councillors from north melford none and
milgrasey
and
two councillors i think the application
might just sit in the southern reward
the whole of the applications the whole
application is what we're talking about
on the first night first item is the
design tile
for for the whole site but it doesn't
say that on the papers
chairman just just for clarity and
apologies the software um
you have to work with to make sure that
more more than one member can be
recognized we know we know just like
make sure we're accurate don't we yes
and and
correctly there are a number of members
interested in the design code across the
whole site and uh the software we we use
apologies has not been fully fully
completed that's down to officers and
we'll take that away as a learning point
and have already done that in discussion
with the ward members
want to make sure we have the time
limits enclosed
thank you council
just a point of clarification first of
all if i could have it and that is
with several mentions within
the papers today of the
mppf
have all members of the committee got a
copy of it
i know i've got one because i requested
one but has everybody got one i believe
you all have
jen my understanding is government's
team we're arranging for those to be
printed and dispatched to members as
requested
you should have electronic format
and a paper format that's being arranged
for those who requested it
all right chairman i'll pick that one up
with uh with the corporate manager for
governance but i had understood that was
being arranged so apologies that it
hasn't necessarily happened
okay
any other questions
if not
case officer jasmine weining island to
introduce the specification to the
committee that's when all yours
thank you chair and good morning members
i'll be presenting a discharge of
conditions application to you today uh
relating to condition 8 of the outline
permission for chiltonwoods
condition a is for the submission and
approval of a design code for the
development which will be discussed in
detail over the coming slides
design codes are not intended to provide
highly specific details and do not
solely focus on the appearance of
development as much of this detail comes
through reserve matters applications
members are therefore encouraged to
think about how this design code
responds to the needs of people how it
creates a sense of place how effectively
utilizes space and how it encourages and
facilitates activity
it should be noted that this design code
will provide a benchmark upon which all
reserve matters applications are
assessed
including the next reserve matters
application you will hear today which is
for the first phase of residential
development
the submitted design code is
comprehensive and totals 135 pages
members are therefore reminded that this
presentation should be viewed in
conjunction with the committee report
and submitted documents which are
viewable on our website
here we have an aerial map covering the
whole chiltonwood site the site location
was defined at the outline stage
the site falls within the four parishes
of acton chilton long melford and
sudbury and is located north of the a134
in creating a design code the site
constraints must be considered to ensure
the development is responsive to its
surroundings
there are several public rights away
running through and alongside the site
as shown by the green lines on the map
the site is not within any special
landscape area nor area of outstanding
natural beauty
there are several nearby listed
buildings to the south but all of which
fall outside of the site
the scope of matters for consideration
within this application are limited to
the matters covered by the condition
with key aspects highlighted in bold on
the screen
the determination of this discharge of
conditions application thus lies on
whether the design code as submitted
either records with or does not accord
with the wording of the condition shown
on the screen
it should be noted that the condition
does not require the design code
to cover the entirety of the development
and covers the residential area village
centre and market square land
the condition also requires that
extensive public consultation and
engagement has been carried out in
creating the design code
the submitted design code follows
significant levels and periods of
consultation carried out by the
developer
this consultation includes regular
thought fortnightly meetings and updates
with members and parish councils which
have occurred since september 2020.
members of the public have also been
engaged with through newsletters online
consultation and social media
condition a is linked to the land use
parameter plan as shown on screen which
was approved at the outline stage
the wording of the condition requires
the design code to cover design
principles for the brown yellow and blue
coloured areas shown here
whilst these are the only areas
strictly required to be included within
the design code adjacent areas within
the site have been considered when
creating the design code to ensure there
is a coherency across the site
a design code is first and foremost a
framework intended to guide development
it sets a benchmark upon which to assess
subsequent applications against
they are a particularly useful tool when
applied to large-scale strategic sites
such as chiltonwoods as they ensure that
development is delivered in a coherent
and fluid manner regardless of who ends
up developing the site the guidance for
creating design codes is primarily found
in two key government created documents
which are the national model design code
and the national design guide
both of which are based around 10 key
principles which are shown in the
left-hand chart here
this chart was taken from the national
model design code and it sets out
aspects under these principles which
design codes should and could cover
however members should note that the
national model design code acknowledges
that the aspects that could be covered
may not be included within design codes
but maybe instead
but may instead be delivered through
other applications such as reserve
matters
the charts on the right-hand side
have also informed the children's design
code and come from the building for a
healthy life document which echoes the
key principles within the model design
code and design guide
here is the contents page of the design
code to give you an overview of what it
covers and how it flows
the code is based on the key objectives
foundations and parameters of the
outline of planning permission
the code makes specific preferences
throughout to local context history and
character within weber the code is
heavily illustrated with photos diagrams
and illustrative plans to demonstrate
the vision for the site and ensure all
reserve matters can be easily conceived
and tied to the code
more generally design codes are intended
to be broad and principle-led and are
not required to set out every specific
detail of a development to this end the
design codes provide provides adequate
flexibility to ensure that delivery is
not compromised but ensures there is no
ambiguity about what is expected from
each development phase
design codes are supported and
encouraged within the newest version of
the mppf
of notable relevance is paragraph 135
which seeks to ensure that high quality
of development
and design is secured throughout the
development and it's not weakened as
time goes on
this is specifically relevant to
chiltonwoods as in as it is anticipated
to be
to be delivered over several years
a landscape-led approach has been
adopted throughout the scheme placing
emphasis on formal and informal green
space with 54 percent of the site being
multi-functional green space
key consideration has been given to
ecological and biodiversity net gains
play areas community woodland street
furniture and suds
notably the majority of suds and
associated landscaping have previously
been considered and approved under the
earlier infrastructure application
the site-wide coding section of the
design code includes guiding principles
to be applied across the development
the outline planning permission ties all
reserve matters to this plan on screen
which sets maximum building heights
across the site the design code builds
upon this and accords with this plan but
encourages some variation heights within
these areas but not exceeding the
maximum
stated on the screen
this plan illustrates and categorizes
key areas within the development that
will be responded to within reserve
matters in a range of ways which would
include for example using taller
buildings in locations to act as focal
points
this assists with the legibility of the
site by helping people navigate around
it by creating a distinctive sense of
place
this street hierarchy plan provides a
clear strategy to apply across the site
and ensures there are adequate linkages
whilst also reinforcing legibility of
key areas
building upon the street hierarchy plan
this plan sets out means to encourage
active transport and secure high levels
of connectivity which ensures the site
is permeable through a range of
transport means
the public transport strategy ensures
that all future occupants and wider
members of the community are well served
by public transport within accessible
distances whilst helping integrate the
site within the immediate and wider
locality
the site-wide coding section also covers
a range of acceptable parking strategies
a study of building topologies and form
refusing recycling strategy and
sustainable design and construction
principles as also out within the
committee report
six key character areas are set out and
apply to different areas of the site
these character areas will aid the
creation of
a sense of place and identity
which is coherent but distinct enough to
help aid legibility and distinctiveness
whilst avoiding common pitfalls of
volume house building where residential
estates become maze-like and identical
throughout
two are proposed across the development
utilizing different textures colours and
materials to again aid a sense of place
whilst responding to the suffix
vernacular and helping reinforce
identity within different character
areas
the first character area is the most
rural to reflect its edge of settlement
location
dwellings will primarily face onto
woodland areas for natural surveillance
and soft landscaping will feature
heavily
the dwellings will comprise of two and
two and a half stories and will be
either detached or semi-detached all
dwellings are to be laid out on informal
drives and lanes these areas will be low
density of less than 30 dwellings per
hectare
the village centre will act as the hub
of the development and is a site of
significant activity with a mixed use of
community buildings commercial and
residential spaces
as it is a central point of the
development it will have slightly taller
buildings potentially three and a half
stories and a higher density of greater
than 41 dwellings per hectare
hard landscaping will feature more
heavily with soft landscaping used in a
more structured and ornamental way
the village green area provides a
transitional space to the higher density
of the village centre
the northern area will be will be at a
density of more than 41 dwellings per
hectare
whereas the southern area will be at a
lower density of around 31 to 41
dwellings per hectare
again dwellings will be between two
stories and three and a half stories
the village green itself will be a focal
green space and will adopt a more
traditional open green character with a
strong residential frontage facing onto
it again to aid natural surveillance
there will be trees interspersed
throughout this area but moan grass will
predominantly feature on the green
this is a key character area
accommodating the largest amount of
housing there will be pockets of
incidental open space and play
apartment blocks will feature in focal
locations again to age aid legibility
emphasis is placed on preventing car
dominated streets through effective
parking strategies provision and
enclosure
it will feature one to three story
dwellings with two story dwellings
making up the majority of the area
30 to 40 dwellings per hectare will be
the most common density however lower
densities will be used in the more outer
northern areas
there'll be more hard landscaping with
an urban feel to the southern areas of
the site graduating to a more soft
landscaping with a suburban feel to the
northern areas of the site
there will be differences in planting
species used across the site again to
aid a sense of place and distinctiveness
acton lane is a central ribbon character
area across the site and will adopt a
semi-rural character
existing hedgerows will be retained and
form the main feature of soft
landscaping and dwellings will be set
back to accommodate their attention
the area will feature detached
semi-detached and terraced dwellings of
between two and two and a half stories
with generous spacing between the plots
dwellings within this character area are
located on the edge of the residential
neighborhoods and provide effective
transitional spaces between dwellings
and green spaces and green corridors
two to three story dwellings will
feature with three stories in key corner
locations
again there will be a medium density of
31 to 40 dwellings per hectare and
detached semi-detached and terrorist
dwellings will feature
the recommendation is therefore to
approve the discharge of condition 8 as
it has been
effectively set out the guiding
principles of quality design and will
provide a consistent thread throughout
all phases of development ensuring a
coherent development is delivered whilst
enabling the council to resist attempts
to water down quality
the discharge of condition 8 will
further enable subsequent reserve
matters to come forward and will aid the
delivery of the strategic site thank you
for listening
thank you jasmine
are there any questions for the officer
lee
thank you chair
just for clarity
so if we approve
the sign off of this
um
design code does that mean
all
developments on children would have to
be in line with this design
code yes that essentially means
um that basically all development that
comes through in subsequent reserve
matters or other sort of um applications
will have to record with the guiding
principles of the design code unless
it's sort of uh varied in in some way
right
also this is a more specific point
within the design code
how wide are the shared cycleway
footpaths
are they
i think it says three meters in the
design code there's a letter from taylor
wimpy saying they're going to be wider
so which is
probably something to clarify with the
developer um
i think it obviously they will have to
be in accordance with the standards are
set up by suffolk county council
highways but
there is sort of a minimum and obviously
in some areas it may be and that they
are wider
yeah i just this is for clarity really i
just want to make sure i'm
following this
because it's
not quite straightforward is it
so the design guide that you've just
presented
is the design guide that was in the
original outline application or this is
the new design guide that we are now
putting we're putting aside the original
this new one is the one that replaces it
and that's what we're voting to accept
going forward on the rest of the
development
so there was no design code on the
outline permission basically uh
condition eight was put on the um
outline permission which basically means
that they are the developer or whoever
it might be
um has to submit a design code which is
what you've seen today so this is the
design code yes this is a complicated
way of getting around to accepting
design right on the basis that uh that
is i'm now clear in my mind then i would
suppose that we can we go to that far
because
we have questions to the officer all
right so so at this stage i'd ask you
not to
i know you know things at all
thank you
please allow other councillor parker
you'd like to ask questions uh yeah
thank you chair um so with regards to
the design code then it's been
independently verified by luc we can see
that in the papers so at whose behest
did that is is that just good practice
or that as somebody sort of said we want
this independently assessed
i think i'd pass that question over to
stephen stroud
i think yeah
so yeah that's a good question um
councillor parker um this was actually
at the
um
it was um
proposed by officers and agreed with the
working group that this would be a
suitable response to ensure that it
could be subject to due
scrutiny bearing in mind that it is
obviously a technical document as well
um so
an independent external consultancy were
instructed to consider the
an early iteration of the design code
they provided constructive comments and
criticism that was taken on board by the
developer and that has informed the
final draft that you that you have
before you two to approve today
thank you mr chairman uh just a couple
of quick points and i think that
probably uh said part of it comes with
the the next application but whereabouts
on the site
are the household recycling waste center
and the sewage farm
which seem to feature in the
in the reports but
surely they will have an impact on the
design and layout of the
design plan which of course would then
be in breach of that plan and secondly
um
locally accepted designed to reflect a
sense of place is one of the aspects of
the new
planning legislation coming forward in
parliament which presumably will change
the
mppf into yet another
format
has that been taken into account or are
we likely to go back to square one again
on this or be operating with a an
out-of-date set of rules and regulations
chairman
can i pick up on that fairly broad point
um
and perhaps it's also useful to note um
in your table papers you've got a letter
from children parish council um which
sort of touches on this in making
reference to the nptf and that's on page
and it talks about the uh the condition
and the nppf uh effectively overruling
that that's not the case uh the nppf and
the national model design code are
material considerations to your decision
here today uh they don't overall the
condition so the condition continues to
apply the condition that governs the the
build out of this development and the
design code you have before you this
morning
is described in paragraph 2.1 of your
report on page 18. so that's that's the
meat and drink of why we have a design
code before us and what it looks to
achieve
in terms of the nppf and the future
approach to design
the national model design code is
largely unchanged from the draft that
the government consulted on so this has
been
widely known and and
i'm not inclined to think there'll be
any sudden lurch in different direction
i'm not aware there's a definition of
what beauty is which is now appeared in
the nppf
but in terms of changing things i think
you have all the tools here to
create uh good design
and i i'm tempted to think there'll
always be a new national policy but in
terms of
approach
the principles of good design stay solid
through the generations chairman so i'm
not quite sure that we need to concern
too much about future change and we
cannot predict it with certainty
i could just come back on that and say
the principles of good design have been
uh
constant through the generations well i
think some people would look at 60s
tower blocks and say that they were an
abomination
and not something that we could
say stood firm through the generations i
think things are evolving and the idea
of beauty as i understand it from the
government's proposals is going to be
something that's set by local
authorities unless of course that gets
usurped again as it probably did from
the 2011 localism act
any more questions with the officer
casabeer you wanted to go question has
been answered by the chief officer so
i'm satisfied thank you mr jameson you
got one
um thank you chair apologies if this has
already been answered
but what input did we have if any in
this design code was it just
the developer put this forward for us to
sign off or did we have some kind of
input during the putting it together
uh so fortnightly um working group
meetings were held with members and
parish councils which enabled sort of um
key updates and consultation and
feedback to sort of be um
collaboratively discussed
and
i'm not sure if if steven has sort of
anything further to add
yeah sure um
and there's also been input at an
officer level as well from officers
obviously from from this council
to planning officer level and then also
the county council as well both in terms
of
floods and highways
the council has also procured um advice
in respect of ecology and landscape
matters also and all of that as a
package has helped to to shape what you
have before you
just for clarity um you say the the week
the two weekly meetings did that include
uh chilton parish council
yes it did because it seems on their
paper they don't feel they were engaged
okay
anymore
[Music]
hi from mclaren
um just two questions jasmine
and it was read in the presentation
rather than a question around the design
code
um
6.10 page 24 there's a
reference to
the management and i presume this is
post development of green spaces
and that looked to me and i may have
misunderstood it that that will be
undertaken by our own staff because
money has been set aside for that is
that right
um yes so there is a condition on the
outline permission which ensures that
there is a level of maintenance um i
believe there is something in the the
section 106 as well but stephen may be
able to confirm that
um
but yes effectively it will be
effectively managed to ensure that you
know green spaces are maintained in a
usable um
capacity so that is a change actually
is it a change from what we we've done
on other developments don't believe it
is
um
i don't know if steven
has anything to add
yes certainly um yes that's right i mean
this is obviously a significant scheme
and there's a a whole body of
information and documentation which
supports it and running concurrently
with the design code and there will also
be a requirement for
a landscape and ecological management
plan that will be sort of the the more
granular detail in terms of a landscape
and ecological strategy
in terms of the the ongoing management
of areas for instance public spaces
i don't believe that it's settled as of
yet but within the section 106 legal
agreement there is a cascade and a
mechanism for it to
effectively be in the gift of the
council to determine what what happens
and we have the opportunity to take on
those spaces should we should we want
them
i'm sure we welcome that sure
just another question
um
recently we've
proposed that we develop a parking
strategy across
beiber mid suffolk
one of the concerns that were raised
with my discussions was the
parking on grass verges be that new
development or existing
streets
within our district
this plan
that's before us today
do you think that
in any way mitigate you know
perhaps prevents grass verge parking
because that is quite destructive
whether it's an old or new grass verge
um yes certainly so
whilst the design coders are sort of
reflected on in the presentation
provides key keys or broad guiding
principles
and all of the reserve matters will have
to record with policy and the standards
including parking standards and
strategies of the time that that
application comes in
um i do believe that there is there's
definitely um
a distinct element of the design code
which is seeking to prevent parking on
grass verges car dominated streets um by
providing you know adequate provision
adequate strategies and also means of
enclosure to sort of prevent people
parking on those verges um but the
specific detail of that will come with
the reserve matters applications
thank you chair
thank you parker
thank you chad um given that this is a
discharging condition are we expecting
to hear from from speakers on on this um
or is it just for us to determine
sorry we're having speeches we've
[Music]
in which case i have more questions i'll
reserve for for the speakers then in
that case okay thank you
thank you jasmine
claire do we have
a representative in the
planning committee
from children parish council
uh
no chair children parish council were
unable to attend so their representation
is included in the table papers
do we have an objective
nope
so we can move straight to the agent yes
you can
had the name here a moment ago
ruth
sorry anyway
can you introduce yourself because i've
managed to lose your name on my papers
that's it
thank you for this opportunity to speak
in support of this application for
discharge of condition 8 with a
recommendation for approval from your
offices
i'm ruth stainsby a director at
gardner-stewart architects appointed by
taylor wimpey as lead designers
overseeing delivery of the residential
portion of the chilton woods master plan
as you're aware taylor wimpy secured
acquisition of the land parcels for the
residential and village center component
of chilton woods in
the team have developed the design code
to discharge condition 8 which requires
the code to cover the residential land
village center and market square
notwithstanding this the scope of the
design code has been widened to include
detail on a site-wide landscaping
on land which lies within the
applicant's control
matters relating to the construction
management plan and landscape management
plan are covered by separate controls
and should be determined independently
of the design code
for the avoidance of doubt the design
code does not cover land which sits
outside of the applicant's control
detail on these items will be secured by
the relevant parties
the design code has been developed
through an extensive consultation
process with local stakeholders
alongside an independent review
and ultimately it will ensure that a
cohesive and high quality development is
delivered
the content of the code builds upon the
huge amount of consultation and analysis
completed at the outline stage
a thorough site and context analysis has
informed the decisions and this included
a local character study
which allowed us to develop a strong set
of design principles for the whole site
there are numerous mandatory items
clearly identified throughout the
document these mandatory items cover
many issues from the macro to the micro
the area of allotments the number and
size of play areas through to density
building heights key views gateways and
landmarks
there's also a section on the hierarchy
and character of streets
and parking including detailed guidance
on the number of spaces required
and within the character section the
code provides guidance for the
architecture and the landscape
mandatory items include building form
and frontage heights materials colours
details such as brick detailing canopies
and boundary treatments
within the village center section
mandatory items include the provision of
the various uses such as a community
hall market square local workspaces
shops and a pub
the principles of the national model
design code and the national design
guide have been followed
there is also a commitment in the code
for all reserved matters to follow the
principles of building for a healthy
life the industry standard for
benchmarking quality
the application proposals are considered
acceptable by the
technical statutory consultees and your
professional officers
the approval of this application
represents a key milestone in the
delivery of the strategically important
site and new housing for sudbury
we therefore hope you will agree with
your office's recommendation to approve
this application
thank you thank you
for the speaker answer
sorry just for clarity so if we approve
this all phases will be built in line
with this design code is that right
that's correct
all residential phases yeah and um also
how wide are the cycle lanes shared
cycle lane footpaths going to be
i think that question was
to you jasmine wasn't it and then
i think we do need to go back and just
double double check that because it did
change it was something that was raised
within the working group yeah but it
would certainly be compliant with the
suffolk county council guidance
good morning yeah the
the design code sets the minimum um on
the spine road of three meters
there is
and that's for a shared footwear
cycleway with a footwear on the other
side of the road the detailed
consideration of the individual plots
will in most cases have more more
facilities
um
you know strategic spine routes through
through the site but in in terms of the
minimum
levels set in the in the code primarily
on the spine road it's a three metre
figure that jasmine quoted earlier
just to pick up at one point about this
question of this being you know the
version of the code that will guide
everything that's true at this point in
time the code itself
does describe a process of review and a
mechanism thought that it's
in the modern parlance it's an evolving
document so that as the development
progresses and as
uh
as standards change one would expect it
to change with that so the code itself
that you're agreeing includes a
mechanism for its own review
professor parker you hello
yeah thank you chad um i'm just um going
looking at the papers children parish
council have given us a very late
submission quite a detailed um late
submission as well and in it they refer
to a letter that they sent to you in
november 2020 um which is it's in the
appendix here 16 pages long
and chilton parish council contends that
you haven't responded to that is that
fair
we made huge changes to the code
following consultation with the working
group
particularly um one of the big
criticisms at the time was that it
didn't include information on the
site-wide landscaping
because the condition didn't require so
so a whole new section was added to the
code to include
the strategic landscaping
the community woodland for example um
the allotments those sorts of
landscaped areas
we added a lot more detail lots more
imagery on character
i've written a few more things down
there was a lot more sign posting
new policy was actually coming in as we
were writing it so the model design
guide for example was coming in so we
made changes to adapt to that
a lot more detail on the village center
um was put in there in terms of the uses
the size of some of those buildings and
what would be included within those
buildings
um
and some of the structure of the
document was changed and there were just
a lot more measurable
aims if you like in there and more
mandatory items so we feel as a team
we've fully addressed their comments
something i know that which has
concerned the working group is that
taylor wimpey are do not own the whole
of the chiltonwood site so there are
areas um that are not in their ownership
so
part of the community woodland for
example
and the county wildlife site
and therefore part of those areas aren't
included in this code because it's out
of the control
you have a question
yeah
um just one thing obviously with the
side of this side it's not um unknown
that the main developer then sells off
sections of that site to another
developer
um would the other developer then be uh
required to continue with the design
code
that you've that we've actually agreed
today
absolutely yes and that is one of the
main
functions of a design code actually it
gives
it it gives us all
comfort
that if someone else comes on board you
will still get that quality
[Music]
members to address us and we're kicking
off with councillor arty
whatever you want to
councillor maybe you have five minutes
to address the council by the committee
thank you very much mr chairman and
thank you to my colleague for letting me
go first
and first of all i would like to
start by saying councillor barrett
raised the issue about the entitlement
of this document
um i did raise that
earlier
about two weeks ago
and i'm sorry that
to see that
the title of this document was not
altered
um
i have
i'm sorry that
chilton parish council is not here but
personal circumstances
at the moment
prevent lady hart from attending
um and i send my sympathies to her
i would like to state
the design code is simply too vague in
places
filled with possibilities and
qualifications
it is not a blueprint
that specifies what is intended to go
where
it speaks of a landscape-led approach
but its description of the green spaces
confuses amenity land
intended for walkers play areas and so
on with environmentally friendly land
which if it is not to be ecologically
useful
cannot also be used as an amenity
ponds should not be overhung by trees
but placing a pond in woodland is
suggested
the luc report rightly states
that the planning and planting of the
green spaces should be done for the
whole development at the outset
not as part of separate phases of
development under sustainability
it also recommends that the landscaping
needs to show where the different
ecological habitats suitable suitable
for specific species are to be allocated
the village center is a crucial focal
point of the development
but the map shows it to be divided by an
arterial road between an inadequate
triangular green to the south
and the buildings to the north
comprising the community hall
retail outlet pub and work place
even these are described as possible
rather than specific buildings
it is left unclear what village center
buildings
taylor wimpy intends to build
no reference seems to be made to street
lighting what kind of lighting is
envisaged what would its environmental
impact be
who would pay for the electricity and
maintenance of the lights
suffolk county council is investigating
the impact of flooding into sudbury from
the site at chilton woods and is
considering further suds basins
and i would like to note here that that
was a question that i had to raise
the result and its consequences should
be added to the site document
before a design code is agreed
water runoff which supplies established
ponds and moats should be maintained at
its current level
and mitigation measures applied to
prevent pollution of this natural
resource
given the importance of this development
the design code should only be approved
once these issues have been addressed
i would also like to make some further
comments
there's been a comment about the
pedestrian cycle way
suffolk county council will i'm sure
remember that it was i also that
suggested it should be three metres wide
it would have been a lot narrower
the other interest that i would like to
say on this and i might be
drifting over towards the next
application too is that this isn't all
part of an old airfield site
and the design code should really
look at part of that too
we should really really be
appreciating our historical
efforts during
the war and at times of great
concern to the to the parishes and the
country as well as other items
the greatest
fault of this design code i will add is
the lack of community woodland
this is supposed to be part of the
parish where i live but this piece of
land has not been purchased by taylor
wimpey or it was even in
the um the ownership of suffolk county
council
thank you
thank you thank you very much any
questions
nope in that case thank you very much
can we ask kansa arthur you have five
minutes to address the committee
okay thanks um
yeah there's um
there's been extensive consultation and
engagement as you've heard
um and there have been a lot of working
group meetings
i think it's probably fair to say that
either margaret mabry or i
have been present at every single one i
think i've missed two and i think
margaret has missed one
but we
were present for the the one that the
other one missed if you like
i think with something like this you
can't please all of the people all of
the time
it's
rather unusual
that this morning you're not actually
determining a planning application but a
discharge of conditions
or discharge of a condition condition
eight
and
usually you concern yourself with the
determination of an application and the
appropriate conditions attached to that
and you leave
the approval of the the details of those
conditions
to your officers
but in this case as was explained
earlier i think there have been requests
for a fully public decision
by this committee and i think you even
asked for that as a committee
at an earlier meeting
as i have said there's there's been
extensive consultation and engagement
which
as you've heard has informed
changes some of those quite significant
and it's also been subject to a lengthy
assessment
my view for for what it's worth is that
it's good
um much better
than it than it was when it was first
prepared
um it could of course be different
um it may be
um that it could be better but
some of these issues you're starting to
stray into
sort of elements of taste
so some people think that something
looks better
than something else
i think your your decision has to be
is is it good is it fit for purpose
um and and my view for what it's worth
is yes
thank you
councilman
it's all well and good having a design
code but on its own it's just a design
code would it be better for us to
park this for the moment
look at the next item to see how it is
interpreted in an actual planning
application
the order that you take them is is the
decision for for your chairman or for
you um to be honest with you i i don't
really think it makes any difference i
think logically you would probably deal
with the design code first wouldn't you
because the the purpose of the design
code is to guide all of the subsequent
applications
subsequent being after so i think you
would probably do this first wouldn't
you
and then deal with the first reserve
master application
for housing later on
case we'll move on we do have a
statement from
tesla which one you're going to go next
thank you
all right yes thank you mr chairman i
did send an email to the chair with my
comments as i was not sure if i was able
to attend so i do apologize for my
lateness and put it down blame my
grandchildren for that
um however i do welcome this application
and we have waited so many years for it
to come forward so i'm really pleased
that it is moving on
a great deal of engagement with local
members has been facilitated including
chilton very much so by the developer
and many comments and
observations have been taken into
account and actually helped shared this
design guide guide that you're looking
at today
as can be seen in your report the
sudbury town council support this
application but are concerned at the
lack of solar panels but that was their
one and only concern
this design guide although not perfect
it goes a long long way to achieving
this housing development and i i look
forward to the provision of affordable
housing coming forward and i support
this application thank you mr chairman
and again my apologies for being late
any questions from the committee to the
board member
no okay thank you
but moving on we have a statement from
councillor melvaisy yes thank you chad
governor's officer to read it please
thank you
dear mr chairman and members of the
planning committee thank you for
enabling me to address issues of concern
relating to this development
i'm concerned that taylor wimpey has not
seen fit to use this development as an
exemplar to lead the march on climate
change through housing sustainability
and to up the ante in respect of
biodiversity
if we are to counteract the concrete
jungle and all the negative elements
associated with such large scale housing
developments greater biodiversity and
sustainability is necessary only this
weekend the united nations published a
report laying responsibility for damage
to the planet at our feet
only a few weeks ago did this planning
committee flex its environmental muscle
and deferred
reserved matters application i'm not
suggesting they should do likewise here
but i do ask taylor wimpey why have you
not taken the chiltenwoods development
as your exemplar
why have you not future proofed it why
are you not leading but simply following
why are you installing gas boilers
knowing that they will be obsolete very
soon
why are you not giving residents a
facility to collect rain water why are
not covering the roofs of the houses
with photovoltaic panels with any
surplus going to the national grid
this would reduce your co2 emissions
substantially
how environmental is the insulation of
all properties apart from the roof
spaces are the walls and floors fully
insulated
are the windows fitted with treble blaze
panels that reflect the sun thus keeping
the property cool in warm or dare i say
hot weather
i also hope that great consideration is
given to the construction management
plan and the construction traffic does
not utilize aubrey drive or act and lane
however as i have stated previously this
is your opportunity to lead the way and
demonstrate and exemplar sustainable
development thank you very much
thank you claire
obviously you can't ask any questions of
miss councilman raizi so we'll open the
subject for debate
the council parker
yeah well i'll just start off chair just
by saying that um
the terminology doesn't help members
here i mean i'm broadly supportive of
this actually i'll stay and say up up
front but um is this a design code or a
design guide because those two words
have ever slightly different nuance i
mean a guide is exactly that it can be
interpreted it can be molded um a code
is a set of instructions so i'll just be
interested in officer's comment please
uh thank you chairman yes if i if i
start this and doubt
mr stroud can correct me when i go wrong
um
design guides um were quite commonplace
in the past and you know and will be
familiar with the suffolk design guide
as being quite a prescriptive set of um
and usually highway driven
bases for development
so design coding goes much wider so if
you look at the national model design
code you'll see and you look with this
you will see the the width of issues
covered goes well beyond
what would in the past have been the
subject matter of a design guide
i.e roads building heights relationships
and buildings
there is a there is an emphasis in
design coding around how you experience
places about what they actually like to
be in and goes beyond the pure
technical
measurement of things in that very hard
sense so there is an evolution in
language
i think in film if i'm quite honest
that's partly political because the
status of a guide versus a code it's
still a material consideration
i think the point with the code is that
this should not be a straight jacket to
reserve matters but should channel them
down a route because there may be
circumstances where
particular approaches don't work but the
point of design as it has evolved in the
past 10 15 years
has to become an exercise has become an
exercise where developers are not
prescribed what they do but are
encouraged to
show their thinking as to why they have
reached a point in design and with
design coding where that is done with
communities there is an exercise of
co-creation and discussion about the
practicalities of this
taylor wimpey are a large national house
building company we must be realistic
that most houses
on large development sites are provided
in that way
nonetheless it is possible to create
areas and to create developments which
have their own character and we've seen
enough stories on the news which reflect
individual
individual developments that haven't
worked in the past and uh council hinton
kind of referred to some of the lessons
of the 1970s so design coding and design
guiding i don't think the language is
especially helpful or
problematic in this instance we've got
to work with a planning condition which
requires a design code the point is that
it should show the way
to lead the subsequent reserve matters
on this allocation site your policy cs4
and the core strategy clearly allocates
and sets out the parameters what the
development should be the design code
puts
some of the flesh on the bones of this
but ultimately it is not an absolute
straightjacket over what you you now
have
and to that extent
you know i don't think the language gets
you that far and i wouldn't be concerned
by it
so um i don't know if that at all
answers your question
counselor buzzfeed
could the officers respond to the letter
from counter councillor mal vasey please
in terms of future proofing and
sustainability
and yes certainly i think um the chief
planning officer has already referred to
the fact that there would be a need for
the design code to reflect and review as
the scheme progresses and obviously
therefore the developer's got to be
cognizant of changes in in the law
and other regimes separate to planning
for example the building regulations
where at the moment it is entirely
lawful for somebody to a developer to
propose
a gas gas boiler nevertheless we do
still have policies that require
betterment to be made over and above
building regulation standards in terms
of efficiencies and co2 emissions and
that's the standard that we would be
considering current reserve matters
applications mindful of course that
there is a plan at examination at the
moment which sets an even higher
standard and as that progresses and
eventually when of course that plan is
adopted there will be a new standard
that the developer will have to accord
with um and and indeed you know that
would be material for all matters
applications coming forward but this
gets back to the relationship between
the design code and of course those
future reserve matters applications
where the code provides the code and the
framework
the reserve matters will provide the
granular detail and have to of course
deal with
the relevant requirements prevailing in
the policy context at the time
yeah i think stephen's answer what my
question was going to be but it's just
that
councilor melvaez's point was sort of
trying to future proof something that's
not on the statute at the moment which i
think is not certainly we can actually
vote on
so
she's asking us to put something or
recommend something that maybe
is in the future but is actually not on
the in within our power to do at the
moment and that strikes me as a bit yeah
i mean we'd all aspire to it but it's
not there at the moment so presumably
when and if building rigs change that we
go forward then those buildings will be
up to date with the future phases that
come in which is what we've got to look
at so
nice that she puts these points but
totally irrelevant to our conversation
today
but nothing we can answer yes
um chairman it's it's one of those odd
situations you're dealing with a
discharge of conditions so it's not a
planning application you can't rewrite
the outline permission whether we like
it or we don't we must deal with that as
our baseline
and members will
be aware that i've already
expressed my opinions about
trying to
reverse engineer some of these things we
have to work within the scope of the
decision that we have and the policies
that we have if they are not adequate we
change the policies if they then lead to
a need to evolve the design code then
that we will do and as steven has
described there is a design code review
mechanism and as our new jlp comes in
logically one of the things that we
would review is what that expects of
this development in future phases
thanks for james
um
in reference what's just been said
although we
can't force
the developers to do things beyond
building code if the developer is saying
they're going to do something in this
design code
surely we should be able to push that as
a minimum of what they're going to do
even if i mean otherwise if they're
going to go
you can't push
push them more than what they said in
the design code but surely we can
ask them to do at least what they're
saying they're going to do in this
design code
oh it is um
i i'm sorry cancer jeffy i didn't quite
followed the question but i think
the the i think i got the the spirit of
it which was we should be doing the best
we can to push developers to go above
and beyond
is that is that well so yeah yeah we
should but i mean if this developer is
saying in this design code they're going
to do x
um surely we can at least say to them
well you've got to do x you've said so
in the design code why are you going
back and doing something worse
well well certainly but at the same time
when we've got the the application in
we've got to consider the the policy
context that's relevant and clearly if
there is a attention that tension will
have to be resolved whether that
requires a review of the design code or
or not um i think all i would say in
terms of the application that you're
about to consider
obviously you'll be considering that
against the current development plan and
mindful of the design code that you may
or not may or may not be approving in a
few minutes
um that phase of development of course
um is for
hundreds quite a lot of housing hundred
and something houses you know
realistically that's going to take a
couple of years to build out
one would think that by the time that
the next phase comes into play then
clearly the developer and i think
they're probably thinking about this
right now
what they need to do to meet whatever
standards are going to be coming in but
that wouldn't necessarily be relevant
for this particular phase
um i think our officers are on the ball
with this you've answered all the
questions i'd like to propose that we
accept the officer's recommendation okay
yes thank you chad our second council
abuse proposal thank you thank you very
much
any more comments before we go to a vote
on the proposal to approve
to to
approve it carry on if i could just just
clarify to you describe exactly what
we're going to
certainly chairman and just to correct
things on your on your front sheet it it
rather ambiguously describes uh
recommendation blank planning commission
listed building consent um it's none of
those things chairman just for the
record
um so the recommendation before you is
is also um perhaps a bit more mercurial
than i would hope
um
and bearing in mind i've probably had
some hand in writing it that's my fault
so the recommendation on page 29 rather
than authority to be delegated to the
chief planning officer to determine and
discharge application uh condition eight
of the outline planning commission uh it
will be to approve and discharge
condition eight so just for the record
that will uh give effect to your
decision today thank you chairman okay
with the proposal and secondly thank you
any more comments if not we'll go to a
vote
okay everyone piece of kind
thank you chair
members if you go to your
excuse me mod this
vote is now in progress
everyone voting
thank you chair yes that's uh 10 votes
for that's unanimous so that's a
unanimous decision thank you very much
um can we now please take just a five
minute break to allow the officers to
clear some people
from the room and bring some others in
um can you please wear your mask as you
go on the corridor and and five minutes
which means
we're all in place we're all refreshed
okay moving on
to dc 21012764
chilton woods mixed development to the
north of woodward business park
subreddit
i would like to invite case officer sam
samantha
to simon summers to present the
application
thank you chair good morning members um
just to
point your attention to the late papers
um you have received um a letter this
morning from chilton parish council
objecting to the application
and also within the papers themselves
there is a statement from the developer
just addressing some of the issues that
highways raised during their
consultation response
uh this application addresses reserve
matters for layout appearance scale and
landscaping for phase one of the chilton
woods development
phase one is a residential development
of 200 houses
the chilton woods development is to the
north of sudbury
is within the parishes of chilton and
sudbury
outline planning permission has been
granted for the erection of up to 1150
dwellings
15 hectares of employment development a
household waste recycling centre
district heating energy center village
center comprising retail village hall
primary school preschool and car parking
new vehicular access points sustainable
transport links community woodland open
space sustainable drainage sports
pavilion playing fields and allotments
today's application concerns this plot
of land that is outlined in red
and is to the southern part of the
chilton woods
development site
this is an area photograph showing the
site within the pink hatching um
acton lane runs along
this field boundary here
and actually through the site
dividing it into two separate areas
on the eastern side is the larger area
with the anderson's development which is
currently under construction in this
area here
we have some areas close along here
aubry drive is in this area here
and reynolds way just here
the site of the old middle school
which is now closed is in this area here
this is the site outlined in red it
shows the existing development and also
uh the development that is currently
under construction the anderson site
just here
there isn't really very much in the way
of constraints to the site apart from
two
oak trees which have a subject to tree
present protection orders
and they're on this western side just
one there and another one just there
this is the layout of the site there are
two
two access points proposed
one from albury drive
and the other one from the reynolds way
and acton lane junction just here
the access points were agreed at the
outline stage and details have been
agreed under the major infrastructure
works application
that members heard earlier this year
this is the layout plan showing the
dwellings
the roads parking areas paths cycleways
and landscaping
what members should be concerned about
for this application is the land inside
of the distributor road which goes
around the outside of the site
here
that was actually agreed under the major
infrastructure works um so it's
literally everything within that area
action lane
will be
vehicle-free
making it safe for pedestrians and
cyclists
this is particularly important because
it links the primary school site which
is this area just in here
to the rest of the site
there's pathways and cycleway link that
runs up through the site
up to that action lane and then it
carries on through along here
and that also links everything to the
school site
the paths are all the way along the
highway and also through the open space
areas of the site the cycle way cuts
through the sites and along acton lane
acton lane
will form an attractive green passageway
there are open spaces
[Music]
for sustainable drainage along acting
lane
there are six apartment blocks
which which are served by parking courts
they're located just here
another one here
two just here
and then a further two
in that western site just there
there are also parking courts to serve
other dwellings um within the site it's
a little bit difficult to see the detail
on here
but they are scattered around the area
in this sort of locations
um
most of the dwellings do have on-site
parking uh but the smaller dwellings and
terraced housing would be using the
parking courts that are set behind the
main highway
this does mean that
the area is kept pretty much
vehicle-free and is not car dominated
when people are traveling around the
site
this shows the cycleways uh sorry for
the odd angle of the plan but i thought
it would be easier for members to sort
of understand the site if i was to
orientate it the same way as the other
plans that we've had
so the green dotted line is the cycle
way
through the site and forms part of this
application
the orange lines around the outside
outside of the boundaries and they forms
part of the major infrastructure works
including
the cycleway through acton lane here
phase one is a residential development
comprising 14 one-bedroom apartments 22
two-bedroom departments
18 two-bedroom coach houses 45
two-bedroom houses
93-bedroom houses 14 four-bedroom houses
and seven five-bedroomed houses
so as you can see the
most of the housing are quite small
houses rather than the big executive
houses that
we often see on developments
this is a plan that shows the location
of the units
so the gray color is the one and two
bedroom apartments
the pink are the two bedroom coach
houses
yellow are the two-bedroomed houses
beige color are three-bedroomed houses
blue the four-bedroom houses and the red
are the five bedroomed houses
[Applause]
this plan shows the heights of the
buildings proposed
there are no bungalows proposed however
there are
ground floor flats
that disabled people or elderly people
might be able to use if they have
problems with
movement
the
sort of creamy colored buildings that
you can see on there that are marked as
single story they are actually garage
buildings
the golden color are the two-story
buildings and then the orange colors are
the two and a half story buildings which
include the apartment blocks and
dwellings with dormer windows
the height of the buildings was
restricted was restricted by the outline
permission and there will be
no building above 10.8 meters in height
in phase one
the two and a half story buildings have
been used to help residents and visitors
to find their way around the development
and are used as pointers
this shows the location of the
affordable dwellings um yellow are the
privately owned dwellings and purple the
affordable dwellings blue the shared
ownership dwellings and as you can see
they are actually pepper potted around
the site
there are a total of 85 affordable
dwellings proposed
on this site
this equates to
42.5 of the total of 200 dwellings
which means that a high number of the
affordable units are being delivered
early within
the chilton woods development
these are some photographs of the area
and if we just go from the top here
these this is reynolds way and the
houses within reynolds way
you're just seeing the junction with
acton lane just here actually
this is the actual junction with
reynolds way in acton lane and from this
point
we would be pedestrianizing this area
and
access to the western site would be
through this area just here
down here we have rayleigh road and
acton lane
and
this one shows the play area to the
south of acton lane and hawkins road
close to the old middle school site
this is taken from inside the site
looking out towards rimmer closer and
reynolds way this one here
these are houses to the entrance of the
eastern site on aubrey drive
and this is the access point to audrey
from audrey drive into the eastern
largest site just here this area here is
what you're seeing
will be the public open space where
the suds is contained the formed part of
the major infrastructure works that was
decided earlier this year
as you heard in the previous
presentation the outline permission
required that a design code be agreed
between the developer and the local
planning authority
the design code would be used to inform
the different phases of development to
ensure that a coherent development is
built
built that blends with its surroundings
and ensures the character of
chiltonwoods
as a whole reads as an attractive
extension to the existing development of
the area
the design code has identified phase one
into three different character areas
the brown color is the residential
character area
the center of the site in pink is the
acton lane character area and the green
area around the edge is the parkline
parkside and linear green
linkages character area
the residential neighborhood character
area includes a variety of building
types which include semi-detached
terraced cottages coach houses and
occasional detached weddings
traffic is calmed by designed to
encourage walking and cycling and shared
services are used
courtyard parking has been designed to
keep traffic away from public viewpoints
so that streets are not car dominated
there is a medium density of build
buildings are finished predominantly in
brickwork with some render in lighter
tones
roofs are finished in composite slate
pen tiles or plain tiles
and detailing includes gables with
pinterest boards
brick detailing and occasional chimneys
the acton lane character area is in the
center of the site and divides the two
developments
develop dwellings are mainly
semi-detached and detached this area is
pedestrianized and cycle friendly
houses are set back from acton lane to
allow it to allow existing hedgerows to
be retained
houses look out onto acton lane and
provide natural surveillance of the area
the houses are larger and have garages
lighter tones of brickwork and rinder
are used to finish the buildings with
tiles or composite slate to finish the
roof
detailing on gables
dormer windows brickwork detailing and
chimneys are design features of this
area
front boundaries will be softly planted
the parkside and linear green linkages
are mainly along the eastern and western
boundaries but also wrap along the
northeastern boundary these areas
provide the the boundary between belt
form and the public open space
the dwelling space onto the distributor
road this is where the apartment blocks
can be found along with other types of
dwellings window placement encourages
natural surveillance of the green areas
the heights of buildings
give variation and help to break up the
belt form
vocal buildings are used to waymark the
area so that people do not get lost or
confused when traveling around the site
chimneys and dormer windows give some
interest
dwellings are finished mainly in brick
of a darker tone
than the other two areas in this
development
with some render in lighter colors which
help to weigh mark
taylor wimpy has entered into public
engagement with a working group of
interested parties from
parish councils suffolk county council
and also district ward members
these
meetings have been held on a fortnightly
basis and have discussed both the design
code and also the phase one development
concerns were raised about the apartment
blocks which are two and a half stories
high
and how this may have an impact on the
existing
dwellings in saint mary's clothes but
also the dwellings
that are currently under construction in
anderson
in the anderson development
the
taylor wimpey have provided some
drawings here
that show the distances
of the development from the other
development areas with a minimum
distance of 40 meters
on this area here we have distances of
over 100 meters
these distances are considered to be
acceptable
in general terms it's recognized that
back to back distances are generally
acceptable at 25 meters and this
development far exceeds those those
measurements
as members will have noted from looking
at the detail of the application there
are a lot of house types
so rather than take you through each
individual house type i thought it might
be more helpful to actually have the
street elevations
where you can understand a bit more
about the mix of housing the materials
used and also the spacing between the
dwellings
this one shows the dwellings along the
cycle way um
there is variety in the mix of dwellings
and also in the colour of the buildings
that use the lighter tones of brick and
render
dwelling space out onto the cycleways
for natural surveillance
dwellings are larger on acton lane
with garaging
materials are the lowest the lighter
tones again
um and there are many trees that you can
possibly just make out they're quite
faint um along the roads here
this is the northern part of
acton lane at the top end of the site
again they're the larger dwellings and
have the soft planting
treatment to the front
this is the main entrance to the site
from all brew drive the mix and design
of the dwellings is greater
giving giving
a bit more variety in the mix
the brick tone is darker and this area
is within the parkside character area
the block of apartments uh is shown just
here so that you can uh see the as the
height goes up here and that is a two
and a half story uh building which is no
greater than
10.8 meters high
this is
um
sorry this is the eastern edge
and again you can see
see the types of building
along here
we have the other type of apartment
block just here
this is the boundary with the school
site which faces onto the cycle way
another apartment block is shown
just
here
boundary walls are used in these public
areas to give the area an attractive uh
an appearance
and you can just see those in here and
also in this bottom
plan just here
this is the road leading from reynold's
way again there is an apartment block to
help orientate yourself within the
development
and this is the apartment block
blockcare
we are back to the smaller and lighter
tones of dwelling within the residential
character area
looking out onto one of the public open
spaces
a greater variety of dwellings can be
seen here and include the coach house
type
which has the parking uh behind the site
and this is the coach house type of
dwelling just here
and vehicles would move here into the
parking courts behind
there are two types of apartment block
with six blocks over the whole site
there are total of four of this type two
in the eastern site and two in the
western site
there are six
separate apartments in this block each
with two bedrooms there is a stent
central staircase with storage under the
stairs at ground floor level for crams
and wheelchairs
this is the other type of apartment
there are two of this type in the
eastern site each block provides six
apartments with one bedroom
again there is storage for prams and
wheelchairs under the stairs at ground
floor level
each block has a garden area suitable
for drying clothes outside a bin and
cycle storage area is also included
one of the features of the chilton woods
development is the large amount of
public open space
apart from the wide swathe
um of open space to the
east of the north
east of the site
of the oh sorry i'm getting myself in
in a muddle
apart from this here which was under the
major infrastructure works we also have
uh this area here along acting lane
this one just here and then this area
just here which also um adjoins the
acton lane area
these green spaces uh give
a nice relief from the build form
and from the plan you can see the two
oak trees that are marked with the red
stars
that are subject to the tree
preservation orders they are to be
retained
the main public open
spaces
as i've said are along acton lane itself
with this central green just here
and then also this green area along here
this is the northern part of acton lane
rustic timber post and rail fencing will
ensure that vehicles do not park on this
area
new hedgerow is proposed in native trees
with a wild flower margin along the lane
side
in the southern part of acton lane a
suds swale is a proposed that will be
planted with wild flowers post and rail
fencing will protect the area from
parking
this is the central green area which is
that triangular shape in the
eastern side of the site
it has a play area in its center
this area will have bollards and hedging
to protect it from parking
this area includes a seat and footpath
through and also the cycle way which you
can see just here
this is the western doorstep green
which is at the far end of the site
and there's a nice green buffer
on the western side of the development
with the distributor road this area will
also have a play area and seating with a
footpath through and cycle links at the
northern part of the open space
[Applause]
these photographs
show some of the landscape finishes for
the site this shows
soft boundaries
and the low hedges
that are required in the design code for
the actin lane character area
area
these are the post and rail fences
to protect the public open spaces from
parking
and this is an example of some of the
brick walls that proposed with flint
panels
this shows the detail of the traffic
calming with block paving on raised
tables
this alerts drivers that they are
entering a residential area
and that they should be aware of both
pedestrians and cyclists
hedges and tree planting soften this
development along the edges of the road
this shows the detailing of landscaping
around one of the parking courts and the
apartment blocks
this is the apartment block here this is
the parking associated with it and then
we have these green areas
around the building which can be used
for drying clothes
taylor wimpey has produced some cgi's of
the public open space to give you an
idea of how the development will mature
this is the swale on acton lane
with the larger dwellings overlooking
the open space
this is the central green with the play
area in the center and cycleway links
and this is looking from the large open
area
at the entrance to the site and looking
at the landmark buildings so this is
where render the pale render is used to
waymark that you're entering into the
development site the main distributor
road runs in front of these houses
also you can see
the level of planting that is proposed
along here with the trees just faded so
that you can still see the type of
houses behind
[Applause]
this application seeks agreement of
reserve matters for phase one of the
chiltonwoods development
members are considering layout
appearance scale and landscaping today
these details have been informed by the
design code and have been subject to
public engagement both with the
chiltonwoods working group and also with
the general public who received a
postcard
inviting them to view the application
prior to the formal submission of this
application that you're seeing today
the application is considered to be in
line with the design code and has not
raised any concern from statutory
consortiums
the scheme brings forward a larger
proportion of affordable housing at an
early stage of the development which is
a huge public benefit
the scheme is attractive and provides
green space footpaths and cycleways
which promote a healthy lifestyle
this application is recommended for
approval with the conditions as set out
in your agenda thank you
now move on to questions from the
officer counselor i'm going to beat you
to this one slide 38 sam if we may
slow 38 yes i got that down
um
a couple of points well i think a little
bit three for you um
the
the mix
lacks one mix
did you ask the um
uh applicant whether they'd consider
bungalows
has this been picked up at all because
that is um well they're certainly
omitted i mean the rest of them look
quite nice and what have you and there's
a good mix but no bungalows and that's a
big um miss so i certainly think they
ought to take this on board when
the next lots come along but anyway did
you ask them that was the question
um as you can see the density of build
on this site is quite tight as medium
density build and we're bringing forward
a huge proportion of affordable
dwellings on this site so the land is
actually quite limited in order to put
bungalows in at this stage my
understanding is that as more phases
come forward they will um they will
provide some bungalows
um we do have ground floor flats um
which do provide that single-story uh
dwelling element within this development
well moving on to the blocks i mean they
don't look as attractive as the rest and
perhaps that's where bungalows could
have been considered but i take your
point i'll put the question to the
applicant
the other thing was the parking courts
um
will they be allocated to a dwelling
i'm not too sure on that and that's
probably something that taylor wimpey
would be able to answer during
their
presentation i'll try and remember to
ask that one to them and
um
yes the other thing
can you assure me there is no grass
verges on the ages
of the main roads and the chairman knows
where i'm coming on this
um
which are sort of a green grassed area
with services underneath
instead of
a hard tarmac path because cars do park
on them um you know the sights on
referring to um
we don't want them replicated here or
anywhere actually because they end up an
absolute hostile mr chairman and i did
notice that you'd got or you said that a
lot of the
um play areas
had got a
wooden little um ballard strain whatever
after 10 years who's going to pay for
them and the upkeep
because
um you know they don't last forever
and whilst they may stop the cars today
once one of them fall down or collapse
or rot or whatever get knocked down cars
will be on there and nobody the
residents don't want to pay for them
so that's
can you help on that yeah of course
if you go back to slide 38 you'll see
what council of beer was talking about
in terms there we are at the top there's
a hard road next to the building there's
a grass verge exactly where you were
talking about yes
to the galleries in the fall court yeah
well you might yeah i'm sure you would
that your residents do as well mr
chairman what what the implication is
that that that grass
when wet
gets parked on and then soon becomes an
absolute isil yeah there is very little
in the way of burges
most of them along the roadsides do have
paths
i can see what you mean with this grass
verge though
and i think if members really are
worried about that point um i'm sure
taylor wimpey will take that away one of
the conditions
that is recommended if approved
is that a landscaping plan is revised
because we do have some outstanding
issues around
some of the brick walls
so details are to come further from that
and certainly uh bollards could be
put in those grass verges to discourage
people from parking on them
um could i just come back on that point
could would it be possible because um
glensfied is another place where we've
had this experience i believe
um and i might be leaving that number um
they become an eyesore we don't ought to
encourage any of them and if we can stop
them at this stage we should putting
bullards on them
um
well that really doesn't look very nice
why don't you just tarmac it and then if
the car wants to
stop there it's not going to make such a
mess but at the moment
we will be opening this up
to these problems and i can show you and
i'd like the committee to all come to
great corner on a particular state and
i'll show you exactly what it's like
after two years
not 10.
perhaps cancer beer would like to bring
us some photographs rather than have us
all tramping him on the grass
thank you
councilman mclaren
thank you chad
sam i'm back to the apartments again
um
can you just
confirm we've got across the site this
site we've got 36 apartments
and two
is that right two only are allocated for
disabled use
my question is
why do we not require perhaps not in
every block but some blocks to have a
lift
because
disability comes to all ages at
different times and if i become disabled
i may have to move from my apartment
somewhere else
yeah and this is something that taylor
wimpy uh talked through with the working
group
it's an issue that was raised at several
of the meetings actually
because all of the
apartment blogs are going to be
affordable units it's really difficult
to get a registered provider
on board that is willing to go to the
cost of not only installing it but also
it's the ongoing maintenance
um so it is a tricky situation they are
only three
three floors so um
you know the argument is that are they
really necessary i agree with the taller
apartment blocks you would normally see
lips installed in those
however in this particular case
it's not something that's coming forward
i'm afraid
it might have been good to consider at
least one block
i i think we underestimate how people's
lives change
and that's not just about the elderly
and certainly
i think in the parish council
comment it was saying about young
families because obviously the
apartments are two bedrooms so
it is going to be multi-occupied but
thank you very much son thank you
country hinton you're in the middle
thank you mr chairman um
just a quick one in the description of
the development on page 33 it talks
about the household waste recycling
center which i didn't get an answer to
for my
previous uh
question on this a district heating
network energy center and a bit further
on it talks about
anglian waters assets in terms of sewage
pumping and distances from that as well
where are they on this development
because nobody's mentioned them so far
so um actually those bits are to come
forward at a different phase today we're
literally just looking at the the um
site phase one for the 200 houses
so the comments from anglian water about
their pumping station and protecting
their assets and everything else are
premature
um okay just at a clarification point
for the other members within my village
we've got three blocks of flats each
with six flats in all two bedrooms
no lifts
they're originally um
owned by the by the council
uh now they're about 50
owner occupier but next door to them
are a couple of rows of bungalows
so there was a provision there for all
needs the other thing i would just like
to ask is with
cancer beers talked about
bungalows and need for bungalows what
about
homes for life because they are
multifaceted in terms of
their usage in that they can be occupied
by young families at the start of their
house loading career and continue
through to old age without them ever
having to move
um i believe that um some of the houses
are actually lifetime
homes but that's something that the
developer will be able to answer
thank you chair
i believe the developer for red
correctly has agreed to do double yellow
lines on some of the main roads i wonder
that's one question firstly if you could
just point out which roads they're
referring to
and the other question is any hedges the
border properties are they protected or
can they be removed by future residents
in terms of the yellow lines that has
got to be agreed as part of a section 38
agreement with suffolk county council so
that will come a slightly later date
than this application
stephen might be able to help with the
hedges because i'm not too sure whether
we have a condition
that
protects the landscaping for a certain
period of time on the outline
uh
without pulling the permission up i'm
fairly sure that there is a condition
that requires um aftercare for when it's
planted it's fairly standard that there
would be should they become diseased or
die there's a there's usually a five or
possibly even ten year in this case
after kit
period
yeah same side slide 37 please
it's the one before
okay
does the
does the cycle
route run through the play area
or is it
separated by something yeah no it's just
here actually
it pops out onto the distributor road at
this point here so this one is just a
pathway pedestrian pathway that runs
through the site
okay so we're not meeting cycles and
children
no good
um and the i like the idea that um
you have to put red bricks in the road
to indicate they're in a residential
area the houses aren't big enough to
give a clue
thank you
councillor parker you have a question
um yeah just for confirmation purposes
really um sam so um acton lane that's
going to cease to be open to traffic at
that at that point then yeah so
any traffic going on to act and has got
to go up the b115 or around the round
the bypass yeah
yeah i think it's intended that it will
be going around the distributor road
i should be here
yes just come back on the question to
officer stephen
the aftercare
you're saying that
you you assume and and i accept that
whether it should be there but can i
just point out
the
the implication of all that doesn't
really happen
afterwards um and i know at this moment
i've emailed the chief clan officer
regarding trees that have died on
estates hedges that have fallen down
bullards that have gone missing and
trying to get the
applicant agent back
um because it's not our responsibility i
think at this moment uh it's very
difficult and explain that to the
residents
as far as they're concerned they say
they're paying their council tax and
they want that sorted
so um you know how strong a case have
you got to insist that the applicant
does go back with the maintenance or the
aftercare as they've said they would
um well i mean the condition well i will
check this while well as the debate's
going but the condition obviously is
enforceable um and it it is open to the
council to
work within its powers to do something
should it be expedient um
in terms of uh it would depend upon the
nature of and the location of that
landscaping in terms of whose
responsibility it would be if it relates
to the open space and if for instance
a local body is
managing and maintaining it
with the relevant
contribution that is set out within the
section 106 agreement then it would be
for for them to take that on otherwise
it might be a management company
and it would be their responsibility
so mr chairman you can penalize them
because otherwise we're jumping up and
down saying baby when you sort the
station you're trying to get it and
nothing's happening
well i think it's a very pertinent
question i think
certainly within that first period of
aftercare relevant to the condition it
is open to us to take action certainly
beyond that point it would be um the
responsibility and prerogative of
whoever manages that that space
it's not too relevant to this
at this particular moment of time it's
it's something that's a little bit
historical to you so i think we'll start
the cheap planning opportunity to
perhaps make a comment
um well i wasn't actually commenting on
that jim but thank you for the
opportunity um i mean as with most
modern developments um you know there is
a there is
the the approach to conditions is well
established
um and and you often find that
landscaping is either subject to a
management company which will and to get
back to your point about bollards and
fencing have a responsibility for
ongoing maintenance management then
there is a charge associated with it
alternatively uh it may well be this
comes across the council that's
potentially uh subject of conversation
with public realm i think that's
anticipated in the section 106 and the
logic with that then is it comes with a
commuted sum to anticipate management
costs just such as that replacement
issue
and planting indeed comes in with that
but i wasn't able to mention that jim
i'm just conscious and um
mr hales from uh the county's uh uh uh
flood authority has uh kindly attended
to uh answer any questions the member
had and before he escapes from the room
because he has other commitments i did
wonder whether there were any suds
related questions that um he might need
to deal with whilst we have him in the
real channel
oh
yes john
well if we're going to talk about sons
yes i was looking thinking of the
comments on the parish council were
concerning the
existing water courses feeding existing
streams etc and how if all the water is
gathered up and stuck into a suds pond
somewhere that they will effectively be
lost
has that been taken into account in the
management of the of the sunset or did
design and implications of the subs
areas or are we just going to condemn
the existing uh ponds and streams and
existing watercourses etc to oblivion
thank you
so
the existing flow paths that come down
in sort of two areas in relation to this
development um one to the uh one to the
eastern one to the west
and then converge below the site will be
the main places where the suds
system will be um attenuating and
treating the water overground so we'll
be
using the existing flow paths to to
create those areas to store water
um to achieve the the results that we
want in terms of restricting the flow of
water off the site and to ensure that
the site is protected and also no
increase in flood risk is is felt
downstream so
um to a certain extent yes some of those
existing flow paths will be used to to
deliver the sudden
any more questions for the opposite
counselors
if i may mr chairman um
well it's to do with county highways as
well because the county highways in
their comments on the uh on page 40 are
talking about
the number of the proposed trees may be
less than five meters from the adoptable
roads
but if we've got a three meter footpath
and a five meter
distance for the trees and we're gonna
have some enormous great big wide spaces
in this in this development uh and also
drawing attention to paragraph 131 of
the mppf which talks about trees make an
important contribution to the character
and quality of urban develop
environments that should help mitigate
and adapt to cl climate change planning
policies and decisions should ensure
that new streets are tree-lined
uh i don't think we've got very much
lining on the on this estate we've got
the odd trees scattered about the place
but we don't seem to have an awful lot
of lining of streets or anything like
that and if the comments from the county
council are uh appropriate if the roads
are going to be adopted then most of
those trees might have to be removed
anyway
yeah so the the letter is just
highlighting issues that will need to be
resolved as part of the section 38
adoption process that the county council
will
enter into with the with the developer
it's not saying that trees always have
to be located that distance from the
highway or the footwear it's just saying
that we would need adequate
root barriers and
you know design
details that you wouldn't normally
expect at this stage of the process so
yes the trees can be accommodated
close to the higher weight and as part
of the adoption we will expect to see
details of the obviously the
construction of the highways
construction of the footwear cycleway
and any route protection
uh watering facilities so it's just
flagging up at this stage as part of the
the section 38 process which will like
say
a completely separate process which will
be carried out later on
those issues need to be addressed
so the just for the applicant's benefit
really
okay well thank you very much sam we'll
let you escape for the moment
thank you very much um
moving on
we do not have
public speaker from children parish
council no we have no objective
and we have but we do have sam caslin
who is representing
the
agent
and will be speaking on their behalf
you have three minutes to
addresses thank you
thank you chair and good morning
councillors
my name is sam caslin and i'm a planning
manager at taylor wimpey who are fully
committed to delivering a significant
portion of the chiltonwood site
i'm grateful to have this opportunity to
speak in support of this reserve matters
application
the case officer's presentation was very
informative and the report itself is
balanced and well written and we of
course welcome its recommendation for
approval
the reserve matters application before
you provides technical detail on the
design layout appearance and landscaping
for the first residential parcel
including 200 new homes
communal immunity landscaping and
associated works that will be delivered
as part of the first residential phase
the proposals deliver a mix of smaller
units and family-sized dwellings in the
form of apartments coach houses and
dwelling houses
43 of the homes in this parcel will be
affordable allowing early delivery for
the identified local needs
the proposed scheme also includes the
delivery of high quality communal
immunity space equip local areas and
play provision and soft landscaping
whilst the homes in this phase will be
heated with gas boilers future
residential parcels
at the site will be powered by a
centralized air source heat pump
this is a visionary approach
and we have worked hard to get group
approval for it will be the first taylor
wimpy site in the country to be
utilizing this technology and we hope
it's going to be well
the plan is that it will be in place
well advanced of the parl regulations
and gas boilers are extinct essentially
the designs for the first residential
phase have been informed by an extensive
consultation process with local
stakeholders and key statutory
consultants and the public
they're designed to fully comply with
the technical standards outlined in the
design code
the proposals for the first phase will
deliver a high quality place that has a
distinct character which positively
responds to the local environment this
is evidence through the material palette
applied across the two parcels with
subtle variations of form detailing and
materiality of the proposed apartment
blocks and dwelling houses to positively
respond to the character areas
this reserve matters application before
you has been developed in close
consultation with baby council and
mid-suffolk and suffolk county council
designs highways drainage and
landscaping ecology offices
and we welcome that there are no
technical objections to the proposals
the application proposals are considered
acceptable by technical statutory
consultees and your professional
officers
they represent a crucial step in the
delivery of the strategically important
site and new housing for um
we are thrilled to have the opportunity
to deliver this part of the chilton
woods master plan are extremely proud of
the application we therefore hope you
will agree with your office's
recommendation to approve the
application thank you thank you very
much
council of beer you were the first ones
thank you
um a couple of pints uh we're very
pleased to hear that um
we're going to be the first place in the
country to have these new
energy pumps and uh congratulations to
you to get them as quickly as you can
so that's a step in the right direction
um
the other point i wanted to ask was
about the
um uh i've forgotten what it was the the
park and
the the damage done to the fences and
the um
that you put up in different places and
the bullards and that who's going to
replace these who's going to pay for
them
this is not while you're there this is
when you've gone
that's one
i'd like to do that one first
yes thank you um
i'll probably expect a bit more detailed
comments on the air source heat pump
strategy and sustainability credential
so i won't preempt those i'll await
those um
in terms of the upkeep and maintenance
um on all of our sites um across the
country we um
areas that aren't adopted by the local
the relevant local bodies and the
retained effectively and iron shape will
be go towards a management company so
there will be a management company fee
that we paid by um
occupants and that fee will cover
um
every single bit of maintenance of those
of those public areas including you know
mowing the lawns and restoring repairing
damage as and when it occurs
like to say it good um the other
question was
why didn't you consider some bungalows
in this phase
we did
it's as as
the case officer said it it's
a fairly well it's a medium density
parcel um
we have a number of constraints on this
site and i think across the across the
whole of the site there's it's almost 50
open open space
so in terms of what we decided to do and
increasing the affordable
element of this scheme that was that was
just chosen as a
preferred approach i think for this
scheme we we do know that we'll we
haven't dismissed
providing bungalows and i think there's
there's obviously reference to them in
the design code uh if i may we
we do provide bungalows and we do build
them we build them on on on a number of
sites and especially when members
request them uh in every incidence that
i've had in my time at taylor wimpy
it's there's a bit of a myth that we
struggle to actually sell those
bungalows um and when we do sell them
they are often heavily discounted
well um all i'm going to say on that is
that we'll watch in the future
because i certainly think you may not
have such an easy ride on bungalows next
time and my last point
is um
house if if this committee was minded to
approve how soon would you start on site
we um we we're extremely keen to get
going on this uh on this scheme so
um we would be looking to you know
subject to actually getting the
approval if members are inclined to do
so uh discharge the pre-start conditions
and and and proceed obviously we've got
the main infrastructure works
application approve um approved and
we're going through the process of
getting some of those pre-start
connections
sorry when on site when would you start
on site
we're in a way we've already doing some
of the pre-start stuff already so i i
suspect
should members be inclined to approve
today we would look to to start an
earnest within a few months i think
thank you
thank you thank you james
thank you chair
um okay regarding the air source heat
pumps your design code says you're going
to use them across all the children wood
sites
and you said yourself you're going to
use them across the other phases so i
can only assume that reason not to use
them in phase one is purely a profit
decision and not um
the main driver for this and i i touched
on it in my speech is that we've worked
extremely hard this is a visionary
solution for us as a business so that's
not just our business unit this is
nationwide um i've mentioned it's going
to be the first taylor winter scheme to
be utilizing this
we
it
it's very hard i think as a business to
probably probably adapt and get to this
place we've got capacity for um a number
of there's a gas supply to do this what
this does is actually enables us to make
us a start on site and actually start
building the homes
um
what's what's probably not picked up is
is the intention with the air source
heat pump is that it will actually have
significant capacity to power these
homes so in the future
when the gas boilers you know if they do
become redundant there will be the
option for
these this first phase to connect into
the air source um the centralized src
pump so will you be paying for that in
the future or will that be down to the
resident that will be a choice for the
resident
on a couple of other questions
um the uh pb arrays you say you're
putting them on the flats are they going
to be on other
properties as well
there's a chance i think that
this it's it's extremely complex at my
time limited to respond to these
questions because i can go on for a
little bit but um
generally what we find as a business is
we actually make stronger environmental
gains by going um
looking for a fabric first approach
which means our actual house types now
are becoming extremely extremely energy
efficient and resource efficient
um so it's
we we prefer to actually put the put the
expenditure into making better thicker
insulation higher quality glazing etc
energy efficient appliances
and water efficient appliances as well
the with that said there is i think um a
10 gain within within this application
so there will be an element of um
photo voltaic panels as well so it's
just going on the reflection i think the
detail of that is to be decide um
is to be finalized but um
at the bare minimum it will be the flat
blocks and if you say about glazing on
your design and access statement it says
the property is going to be triple
glazed but on your energy statement it
says are going to be double glazed so so
which is it
yeah i uh
obviously the energy statement is a bit
of a technical detail and i think that
will be approved i think um i would go
on the design code which is what we're
judging this by that um that would be
expected to be using triple glazing here
right and and the one last question if
we can
um
the
there's been mention about w lines
around some of the
um external roads and are they going to
be
is that going to be included along the
cycle route so to prevent people parking
on the um
cycle brick
external cycle route this is obviously
not the internal one
to be honest i'm not sure i might look
to um
the highways authority to respond to
that one thank you
yeah to be honest i don't think that
level of detail is um has come out yet
but it's something obviously we're
cognizant of in terms of
the need to protect facilities from
problem parking but that will be a
matter for the adoption by the highway
authority it's not not a planning matter
really okay thanks
thanks
no more
thank you very much
thank you
after that grilling from cancer
jameson's we
can't let you go
thank you very much indeed
this
i've got an answer for the council of
beer at an appropriate point if you
whenever you want to bring me here
in terms of the aftercare period i said
i'd go away and look at that
go on there
it is five years and that's five years
per phase so each phase when the
landscaping works carried out the
aftercare period is five years however
relevant to each phase is obviously as
we discussed earlier the landscape and
ecological management plan so that would
establish management principles going
through the lifetime of the development
itself the question then is whose
responsibility it is um
and also in terms of the life there's a
question about lifetime homes
there is a
paragraph in the officers report i've
lost it now but it was eight point
something it says that sixty percent of
the units will be m42
obviously that's that's optional but
sixty percent of the units will be that
there are also a couple of units that
are m43 which is wheelchair accessible
thank you steve
thanks right moving on
a
we have
three ward members present um
i'm not even too sure whether they want
to speak they reserve the right to so if
we start as we did it this morning
counselor maybe would you like to make a
contribution you have five minutes
thank you very much mr chairman
um
first of all i would like to state that
there's been a lot of work and time
that's been put into this phase one
development
by officers by taylor wimpey by
councillor members
both parish council and baber
and i commend all of them for their work
it's been
a year
just on of
quite immense
workload
we've always hoped for an exemplary
development
and we will continue to look for this
but i've always been against the strong
affordable presence in phase one
there is a need for housing i do not
dispute that but i've always been
against having a strong presence in one
area of this development
i've also always been against the
apartment blocks on the entrance to the
site
i have argued from day one that these
are not necessary at that point that i
think that they will have a detrimental
view
over the other developments and that
they will not achieve what
is hoped for which is an
entrance there are other ways to achieve
an entrance to this site which i think
we have managed
and that is the wildlife area
along aubry drive
i've also been against the gas
connection on phase one and i very much
welcome today's comment that air source
heat pumps will be on the future phases
i've also always been against balconies
on the apartment blocks which i do not
like in the first place because i can
just see it in the future everyone's
washing hanging out for everyone to see
i am
really against that
i applaud the green nature of this
development we have seen over the last
year that
engagement with nature certainly helps
everyone's well-being
i have also urged disability access
and i commend anything that will help
towards homes for life or disability
i would also recommend that the
disability access is looked at if you
are going to put those apartment blocks
in which i really dislike then please
make sure they are all disability
accessible
i would also like to see a condition
that keeps
all the wildlife built assets
such as the bird the bat
boxes and also the bee homes we need to
make sure that these are not stocked up
these are not removed
when we look at
the thought of bungalows for this phase
one yes it was dismissed but i would
like to add that chilton place which is
the anderson site the bungalows were the
first that sold and there was a rush for
them they cannot build them quick enough
we do actually need more
i would like to end by saying that
this culmination of this phase one has
been a year i do commend everyone we've
had our differences we've had our
agreements we've had our laughs
we've had our ex
our acceptance sometimes that we do not
all see eye to eye but i would really
like the planning committee to consider
those items that i do say i am against
and thank you
thank you for counseling baby um from
your uh address i'm still not very
whether you're for or against this
development
i would i would be i would like to know
black guy
thank you councilman about i would be
for it if those apartment blocks went at
the entrance yeah we can't do that but
that's okay
councillor barrett councillor maybe
doesn't have to tell you it's only the
members of this committee who have to
make their minds up i i accept what
you're trying to ascertain whether the
members fought against in her dress mr
chairman i don't think she made it very
clear whether she was actually for or
against
she doesn't have to
no
yes just picking up on a point that
councillor maybe that is on the
apartment blocks which i do share her
concerns on them i think they're
unsightly um i know we've got some on
the entrance into great corner and they
reckon that would improve i'm sure it
won't
but could i just ask i think she said
that we couldn't do anything about them
is it within our powers to to
pull that out or say we don't like it or
to offer different views on it
or is it are we too late
um chairman it's the reserve matters
application if you don't like the
reserve matters you don't have to
approve them
you're you're as a planning authority
you have that discretion to um exercise
your judgment over that if that's what
committee wishes i thought that was
right and thank y'all
right never questions thank you
councillor maverick oh
can i just pick up on the wildlife point
i think it's also important that there
are there's a there's an ecological
management plan condition on the outline
permissions so
we'd always try not to reproduce
conditions and that's quite quite
detailed in terms of ecological
management requirements across all the
phases so hopefully
in terms of council members expectations
around that that will ensure that
no ecology issues are compromised here
thank you just click on that is already
in place
yes thank you
moving on council arthur do you want to
take five minutes yeah just a few things
if i may thanks that have sort of
cropped up during the course of the the
presentation um and and the questions
um
firstly to thank samantha summers for i
think an excellent um presentation thank
you sam
um i've got a couple of observations and
a question at the end um
i just wanted to say that the outline um
consent exists
um
for chilton woods as you all know this
is just the first phase
there are another 950 dwellings
coming your way in subsequent reserve
matters applications
and just wanted to stress how important
those sorts of numbers are in terms of
our housing delivery as a council
as you've probably
noticed the application reflects the
design code that you've just approved so
that's good isn't it
and i will say the same as i said
earlier about the design code
and that is that in my view the
proposals are good
the suffolk county council have held the
potential development at chilton woods
sort of hovering over
chilton residents and and the edge of
sudbury for over 20 years now
um and it seems to me that the local
community just want to whimpy to get on
with it now they've bought the site um
and the sooner they can get on and start
to provide the houses we need
the sooner the better
particularly as this first phase is
adjacent to the anderson site that's
been referred to
and that site has caused some
disturbance to local residents over the
last two years or so
the question is about page 45 and the
views of our environmental protection
team
where
conditions are recommended and they
particularly refer to a sustainable
sustainability and energy strategy
i can't see those picked up in the
recommended conditions it may well be
that they've been picked up elsewhere
but there are quite a few um
recommendations that have come in from
our own environmental health people at
page 45 so that's that's my question if
i can ask it chairman
verify that
does that mean you've used up your five
minutes you're happy thank you
could the officers
no okay
stephen it's coming down to you
apparently
okay
very good um just let me find what will
you you find out is there any any other
question any questions for counsellor
well while we're trying to find the
information
no okay
how are you doing
uh yes i i think i've i've got it here
um
i think uh it's quite quite a long um
comment i think the most important one
is to recognize that this this
application has been submitted um
pursuant to and in accordance with um
policy cs13 of the core strategy which
requires the 10
emissions reduction over partel which is
secured
in terms of the recommendation for
further conditions to
in effect
uh improve upon that figure
and introduce
other requirements relating to for
instance water efficiency
um i think we need to be mindful of a
couple of things one obviously maybe you
can you can impose whatever conditions
you see fit so long as they meet the
tests and in relation to that i would be
mindful um
not to
repeat any condition that's already on
the outline or indeed go beyond the
remit of of what policies we have which
seek that 10 which is already being
met
i think the applicant has already
pointed out that there are measures um
in place
in relation to water efficiency
um that they're that they're dealing
with
i'm not sure whether
it is necessary to make this particular
reserve matters application
acceptable to impose a secondary
condition um but i leave it for members
whether they want to for instance
understand a bit more about say the
water efficiency measures that the
applicant has
said that they will put into place but
certainly in terms of energy and and
emissions that's already covered and
that's already being dealt with
adequately and i would suggest that we
don't
add another condition which effectively
stretches that point
thank you stephen
okay well moving on we have a another
third board member jan osborne do you
wish to
address
yeah thank you mr chairman i will be
very brief first of all i welcome the
very high percentage the 42.5
of affordable housing that is greatly
needed and is very welcome
and there's been some discussion around
lifts not being available in the
apartments it's not perfect solution but
if it was found necessary for a
particular resident a chairlift could
all could always be considered so that
would be an option to not having a lift
there
i've also raised concerns many concerns
about parking on green areas so i'd like
to see a landscaping plan
to include some form of discouragement
for residents to do this it's it will be
needed there's no doubt about that
council of beer supports that
i thoroughly support that
um and for the sake of the committee
members i fully support this application
thank you mr chairman
thank you
i told you there were no questions
thank you very much
right let's
open the debate
who would like to make the first comment
counselor postman
can you go to slide 27 please sam
it's about the apartment blocks
of course
i just think
the design seems strange i'm sorry
architect but um
it looks as though they've been
truncated looks like somebody's chopped
off the right hand side of the block
i think they'd almost be more
presentable if they had another
kind of wing sticking out
it looks
they just look strange um and i don't
think that helps the
the overall design of it
um the other point i had was that on
i think slide 19 you've got the
apartment blocks at the top of the hill
rather than what we can that will do
actually
if you go back
you've got the two houses at the bottom
of the hill and the taller block at the
top
is that not going to dominate wouldn't
it be better to have the the taller
buildings at the bottom of the hill and
the
smaller ones at the top
i think um what they've tried to do is
to graduate it so from aubury drive not
to dominate
those houses that are existing that you
can just see
here
so by stepping them up slowly even
though it is going uphill
um
you know
it doesn't seem dominant if you were to
put the flats in the lowest part
the people in aubury drive would would
probably find that
you know
quite oppressive
uh well just to be contrary chat um i i
actually quite like the design of that
apartment block actually it's all about
it's all about interpretation isn't it
um
all in the eye of the beholder um and
i've i haven't really got too much more
to answer that
other than i don't i don't i wouldn't be
in favor of some expensive conversation
about moving properties around and
things i actually think if we can
develop that apartment block as it looks
on the um
on the display there if the materials
and things are right i i don't think
that's disagreeable actually
that's all
cancer
thank you mr chairman just rather sort
of emphasizes sort of like beauty is in
the eye of the beholder what somebody
regards as wonderful somebody else
thinks he's an abomination but um
what worries me a little bit is the
there are two things really
firstly on page 41 where at present the
design work has been halted until the
school is required i've copied the count
of cows
well
we don't know what this school's going
to look like it's not part of the
reserve matter it's part of the reserve
matters and yet we haven't got a clue
what it's going to look like because
they've
postponed the
the design work of it and yet it's got
to be in place by
dwelling 150 being in
occupied uh as one of the the major
conditions so i'm a bit surprised that
uh it's coming forward when we haven't
even got all the information from that
point of view and the other one i find a
little bit sort of patronizing almost is
this this idea of they're putting the
big buildings next to junctions so that
people know where they are
um are they all blind or partially
sighted or something you know don't they
know how to find their way around in the
state where all the buildings have a
similar size
it just seems a bit patronizing to me
and it does make those buildings even
more dominant in the in the sort of
landscape of the side
which i think is
in my in my view not very beautiful
thank you
um
thank you chair um yes a couple of
points um about bungalows and stairs as
i've said before
stairs can be good for you as you're
getting older it's good to have the
exercise i live in a first floor flat i
have two false hips and i manage very
well if someone does need a stairlift
baba do give a grant towards that so
that can be useful
um and also
um about washing lines um where i live
their flats and no one i'm sorry
councillor maybe uses their um verandas
or balconies to hang out the washing
and i too agree with
council lee parker and i i don't think
they're too bad i like them thank you
thank you council james
thank you
obviously um i'm going to go on about
the environmental issues of this
development again
now whatever taylor wimpy are going to
do in the future
with regard to this development i think
they're
falling short they're doing just about
enough
there was that i can't see any mention
of gas boilers in their design code so
if if they're not then they're going to
get the design code straight away
um they've had plenty of time to plan
for air source heat pumps
the applicants are saying that they need
they've not
um and they're just passing the running
costs on to future residents as far as
sorry sorry the um retrofit costs onto
future residents and the xavier
environmental protection officer says
the um
the
houses in phase one are going to be
poorer than future ones
um
like there's limited pv they put it in
when they had the opportunity to put
millionaire houses that were suitable
i'm still confused on if we're double
glazing or triple glazing and i can't
see any mention of heat recovery so
i think it's you know considering we're
in a climate emergency i think they're
just just about doing just enough and
not going extra step so as i say it
looks like they're putting profit first
to me
sorry cancer beer
thank you mr chairman um
well
i i'm going to
move the officer's recommendation and in
dawn so i just want to make the comments
and i think councillor arthur brought
the point out this is the first 200
houses
yes it's not a hundred percent ideal in
my opinion um but
we have been promised that they are
going to
have more energy efficient gas on the
floor so that's a good start we do need
the houses
and
i would like to think that you will take
away from this meeting that whilst
hopefully
my colleagues will support this
and you get approval that certainly next
time it may not be quite as easy you may
have to answer some of these things that
we're bringing to your notice now but
certainly
i'm quite happy to move the officer's
recommendation that's in front of us
with all the conditions thank you okay
yeah
um just uh one of the points um about
gas more is i'm pretty certain that
worcester bosch
all future boilers that they're
producing are going to be hydrogen
compliant so it switches over
which you know when hydrogen is
available and i think that might be the
way forward there's already experiment
in the northeast of england so it could
be that the hydrogen situation will be
there and if the boilers are compliant
in that that could be a solution to
lay cancer jameson's fears
thank you very much
any more comments
in the debate
no in that case i'll ask the chief plane
officer to come in thank you yes just to
pick up on the point about uh water
efficiency um uh that perhaps steven you
might just follow on we have a can we
have a reference to that i believe we
can draw out from
the recommendation before you which is
for uh
as is usually in these things i just
find that the approved documents which
we expect the development to comply with
that's condition one on page 73.
within that one of the approved
documents would be the energy statement
which as i understand it and i haven't
read this myself refers to water
efficiency within development
perhaps to make point we might pull that
out and make that the subject of a
specific condition
so that
we ensure the development is carried out
in accordance with
that detailed submission
and that's certainly something that we
can do as a as an appropriate course of
action
uh i don't know if there's anything
specific in that that's otherwise worth
saying stephen
no an apologies i've actually tell sort
of been playing catch up there i've had
a quick look through the energy
statement following that my answer to
the counselor is arthur's cancer
arthur's question earlier
in that
we obviously have a document here which
sets out how the scheme complies with
the current policy context it also does
include within it measures relating to
water efficiency
so we could in effect be absolutely
clear that the development
is expected to comply with the standards
set out within this
document um the only observation i'd
make in relation to that is is that
obviously this document as council
jameson's pointed out i should be
open about this obviously as we've
picked up that it does state that
they're double glazed units um and i
think the applicant had suggested they
may well be triple glazed so
we could feasibly clarify that point
okay
thank you
yes that the office has just been coming
up with yeah i've been looking at the
recommendation on page 73 where it talks
about approved plans and documents but
it doesn't actually tell you what those
approved plans and documents are
action required in accordance with
specific timetable agreement of
materials
in other words what bricks you're going
to get and when accordance with the
specific time to agreement of surfacing
materials in other words what you can
put on the road there's no mention in
there at all of a sustainable and energy
strategy which is what was recommended
by the
uh
the bitbaber environmental protection
team on page 45 which obviously would
cover that the business of
double glazing
air source heat pumps etc and also the
comments put on page 45
about developments constructed with
levels of insulation etcetera and then
goes on to say that it's good practice
to detail these interventions in show
houses for the development with the
option of potential vendors being able
to pay extra for interventions at that
stage rather than suddenly be surprised
in five years time when they've got to
convert their house to another form of
energy at a phenomenal cost so perhaps
those could be put in the conditions in
a more clara
clear
way
assuming of course that uh i haven't
just read this document and it's already
in there
the officers write a comment before we
move on um jen firstly so the standard
condition you have on
page 73 is a standard condition uh model
effectively that we use for all
developments uh you will understand that
there is a very lengthy list of
documents including plans drawings and
other details
attached to this application
and we do not as a matter of course list
those out debating they are effectively
listed on the decision notice and this
condition then refers into that list so
we've got one list we lock into that
list rather than have three separate or
two two separate lists so effectively
the
application documents including the
energy statement for this phase
are part of those what we know is that
that includes uh reference around water
efficiency that was part of the original
conversation and discussion um what i'm
suggesting is that we draw that detail
out of this condition and make it a
specific requirement albeit i think
we've identified
that there is a
an inconsistency in treatment between
the
triple glazing and double blazing point
but from my perspective chairman if
you're content that's uh something that
you can instruct officers to deal with
under a delegation in imposing that
condition and settling the contradiction
in terms outside this meeting
so my recommendation to you if you wish
if the promotion second i want to accept
it is that you had a specific condition
to require compliance with the energy
statement as a specific point what that
will do will draw that out of of those
documents
but to make that subject to
uh a matter of delegation to uh officers
to settle the detail of that
and deal with the
inherent ambiguity that has been pointed
out regarding double glazing and triple
glazing so that we have a document that
refers to energy and other matters which
as
uh mr stroud has pointed out complies
with your policies
and picks up then as well the water
efficiency point that has been raised as
a matter of concern thank you
are you happy to persian secondly um
well i'm quite happy with the ones on
page 45 the one that
the suggestion that the chief planning
officers made about the
condition on the energy efficiency yeah
yeah but i'm not so sure
on the point of whether it's double
glazing or triple glaze and i mean if
they're already
if they can't alter that i wouldn't want
that refused on that
certainly at the next stage they ought
to take away that
triple gauge would be acceptable
but
all right
i've heard triple glazed and double
glazed used here is it troublemaking
their documents and double glazed in
their
their literature or the other way around
so well my point is very clear in double
glazing is acceptable to me if if that's
what they've got um but if you're going
to turn on and say that you want to use
alligator powers to refuse it because it
should be triple glazing that's what i
needed to clarify
apologies for any lack of clarity
chairman if i'm if i may so i'm not
proposing that the officers go away and
refuse this what i'm proposing is the
offers go where officers go away and i
believe the reference to triple glazing
appears in the design code
but the energy statement refers to
double glazing so to settle that detail
and obviously if the design code refers
to triple glazing we would and i presume
taylor wimpy anticipate doing triple
glazing but clearly
resolving that ambiguity in in
fine detail is the appropriate thing
which may involve revising the energy
statement so it's corrected that detail
to be what's actually intended what i'm
expecting that to sit within is an
authority to
prove the reserve matters
um so that's the context that it sits in
and that in dealing with that energy
statement would pick up a water
efficiency point which council jameson
raised and we've had some debate around
i am not
for the sake of the record i'm not
recommending the imposition of the
condition on page 45
because as i think i've said in my email
that's gone around to members about the
ability we have to impose conditions
this is a reserve matters application
the outline permission did not include a
condition in that nature and i think we
have the means in this way and with the
design code to
manage the evolution of energy
efficiency in a sensible way
and to to impose a condition of that
nature would in my opinion go
a step beyond what we can do with the
reserve matters application which sits
within the outline permission which
doesn't contain it
all right okay
fine
okay so we have proposals any more
comments to be made about
proposals with jameson uh just for
reference the triple glazing mention is
in the design and access statement i'm
not sure if it's in the design code any
mention in there at all but it's in a
design and access statement which is
okay
any more comments
on the proposal
no in that case i'll ask
the chief planning officer to
read out exactly what you're
voting for or against
thank you
thank you chairman so the recommendation
before you
is as set out on page
uh but i would and this is a and it is a
delegation to approve the reserve
matters and i would say that that the
chief planning
officer be authorized to resolve the
apparent ambiguity between application
documents in relation to glazing
and that's subject to resolution of that
be delegated to approve those reserve
matters subject to such conditions as he
thinks fit including one
approved plans and documents two
uh materials three surfacing materials
and four
specifically uh
compliance with the energy statement
thank you chairman
you're clear what you're voting on
and i ask claire to begin the vote
thank you chair that vote members is
now in progress
in your app
thank you members chair that's eight
votes four and two against that's eight
four two again thank you
item over right
we were now taking that five minute
break to allow the the officers to
switch the audience
welcome back everyone let's crack on
moving on this is
land of lady lane has suffolk dc 2004
615.
cat would you like to take it to your
presentation please
thank you chair and good afternoon
members
as you hopefully remember this
application was before committee on the
16th of june and members voted to defer
it
for both
a site visit but also further
clarification in terms of the asthma
verdi
viability statement which we we went
back and sort as per one big you know
updated committee report but also the
late papers that you'll have hopefully
seen
site visit was obviously last week
wednesday fourth of august
so it's outline application
with access and structural landscaping
to be agreed
um
for up to
45 wellings
so
these are the videos from the site
just to remind you obviously what you
saw last week at the moment it is
part of the site it will show on a
couple of slides later on and exactly
which part of the site is allocated as
employment and which side falls outside
of this allocation the majority of the
site does however fall in
um
allocated employment land under policy
emo2
so this is again just um videos as
hopefully you all attended last week so
you are roughly familiar
with the site uh so you've got oldham
name which you just saw with the
dwellings on the on the left this is
towards the back of the site in the
background you can see being a ladyland
industrial state buildings
and those dwellings are the ones that
face lady lane and that would be the
site entrance
again
just further videos
so as you're aware obviously hadley is a
key key um employment area so policy
em24 the issues um
raised at the previous committee were
the fact whether this
allocated site was still viable for
employment not specifically industrial
purposes
um just general employment obviously
that could be covered under any anything
within class e it's not specific for htv
use it could be offices
it could be coffee shops anything that
features under the classy regulations so
policy em 24
is the main policy that that office and
we're considering the application
against so in terms of policy em-24
it even needs to be a sustained
marketing campaign for the site
for its employment use
or there needs to be
agreement or demonstration from the
applicant that the site isn't viable for
employment uses
they haven't done or done any
marketing campaigning so they haven't
looked at one they've been looking at
point two within policy m24 which is
solely whether the site is viable for
employment or not
we've we've undertaken viability
statements as part of
obviously the emerging joint local plan
and the agent believes that the site
isn't viable as set out in their recent
correspondence which hopefully you've
seen
and we believe that the applicant has
failed to satisfy
either of the tests they're not looking
to satisfy one that's agreed
but we don't consider that
it's unviable um as per the late papers
so there's a strong objection from
policy
and in line with the
original aspinal verdi report we then
contacted them again to say
is it viable
there is some argument that it isn't a
viable site and it's not been considered
stewart cook who undertook the report on
behalf of asthma verdi
is now working under a different um
different company urba
and he's provided advice
on basically arsenal verdi's behalf and
policy team's behalf on the basis that
he did the previous aspirin or verdi
viability statement
so as i mentioned earlier about some of
the site being within the employment
allocation and some of it not this area
isn't
and it hasn't been within the allocated
employment land it wasn't in the adopted
plan and it isn't in the emerging joint
local plan
and this is the area that is still in
the um allocation for employment
so i'll see
you know there is part of the site that
falls outside of the employment
allocation
but the remainder is still within it
on the emerging joint local plan
so and this goes into the application
that was
before you on the 16th of june so this
is also the wider context of the site
so there are very limited constraints on
the site
in terms of conservation area there
isn't one and there is a listed building
wall to listen wall to the front of site
and again as i've just mentioned the at
the moment the
most of the land is allocated as
employment
we've had policy um comment previously
when it was brought to members
beforehand on this i think they
commented the 9th of june their comments
remain as documented in late papers
um there's also
you'll hear later today cobalt's farm
which can is both applications are dealt
with separately but there is a potential
way to tie the two together if we were
looking at
approving if members were minded to
approve the current application site for
houses but still wanted
employment land cobwebs farmers the
application will follow this one
so again this is in the adopted local
plan
the the area that's allocated
and this is the site in question
as you can see it's the image is smaller
but there's a front square of the site
that isn't in the allocation
emerging draft joint local plan again
the site still falls within that one so
and it has been considered as a small
square that was um
outside of it previously
is is still outside of it and the
recent i say recent they were built um
quite a while ago now but there's some
dwellings that have now been put on lady
lane they're now taken out of this
this allocation
so this is a site
see the adjacent
haulage yard that's i think being used
by a current company
so we've got the nodes here
so this will be the access to the site
and this is like a cycle and pedestrian
access there'll be no vehicular access
here
it will solely be through the site here
for this proposal
um we don't consider it landlocked
in the sense that any proposed
employment use would would use this
this access um
obviously they wouldn't come down from
the site and as members would call
there's a high embankment so for
vehicular access there is no
you know we're in agreement there's no
access
through lady lane industrial estate but
there is a potential to access the site
still
this is just a perimeter plan so you can
see it in context
again this is the existing um in blue
it's owned by
by the applicant or members of you know
applicants family
so this is a topographical survey plan
again because it's outlined that the
actual design of the scheme is the
reserve matters so
the potential
building placement could you know could
come at the reserve matters stage
this is a proposed landscaping
so the existing
retaining wall that exists on site
um will also
be retained with extra planting along
here towards the end of the site there
will be an area of sort of open space
and planting
this is just close up and gives you an
ideal see the plants that
are proposed
they are providing as part of it a
footpath from the vehicular access of
the site down to the bus stop so this is
the vape for access onto the site
and this is
the footpath they'd be providing towards
the existing footpath and bus stop
these are just some photographs but
hopefully um these will kind of be
more informative now that you've
actually visited the the site so again
this is the vic your access point
this would be the pedestrian and cyclist
kind of access point
this existing yard is at the top of the
site so
here
so as per the previous recommendation we
recommending refusal on the basis that
it's contrary to the existing
development plan as well as emerging
policy as an allocated site
and our viability statement and the
addendum that's in the late papers
agree that the site is considered still
viable for some form of employment use
although it may not be industrial hgv
lorries
it could be other classy uses
this of the town council
we have no injector
no supporter
so we're going to go straight to mr
leslie short as the agent thank you
sorry do you want a nice question yeah
okay
yes
is there any part of this site
allocated for housing
and if there is have you got a screen
picture to show it please
there's no part of the site that's
specifically a housing allocation in
terms of within a plan but there is a
segment of the site that falls outside
of the employment allocation so
therefore
it's reasonable to say that um housing
could go on that part
i think it's pretty much at the start
what
parts this red part so this red part
isn't color blind that all looks the
same color to me you see other than the
yellow where's the red part
i think you recognize blue
quickly comes in
yeah well whilst you've got that that
slide up isn't it correct that you said
that that's red it's not employment land
but wasn't there an exact planning
commission on there for
business units with accommodation above
dating back some years now i've been on
the council too long now i suppose but i
can remember that application coming
forward when it's converting from a
builder's yard into
business units around in a sort of
semi-circle with accommodation above
quite possibly i don't know the ins and
outs it would just be um i can only see
re-read the history
okay um
i'm not aware of any but obviously i've
not been in the council um particularly
long um and relied on on what came up on
our searches
um there is potential that that was
obviously a planning application at some
point it's never been
um built out or if it has it's you know
it no longer exists so but it's not not
necessarily a consideration as to what
it has previously had a permission for
wonder why if why that hadn't been
included it's employment in the jlp
along with the bit at the back i mean it
hasn't it wasn't included in the adopted
local plan so i i imagine that the
reason it's not going to be included in
the jlp is because it hadn't been
adopted
back then as to why it wasn't included
that would be a question for policy um i
i couldn't answer that one i'm afraid
how so far can you quickly
um yeah well it's just for clarification
chair really because um obviously
we've got two applications that have
here now um the the report mentions or
your presentation mentioned the
subsequent application
so are we considering this application
in total isolation to the next one is
that is that what we're doing
total isolation yeah they're to be
considered on that on their own it's
only if um
members want to tie them together
so say you were going to approve this
one and also cobbled and wanted to say
that yes we're happy for residential use
on this site but we
we want an employment use elsewhere to
make up for it make up for the loss then
then we'd have to look at section 106
and so on to agree and that's why the
agent has brought the map forwards as
is kind of a
a swap so to speak but the applications
are in front of you to be considered
on their own
okay thank you okay
okay no more than i lost
leslie too
before i start my three minutes i don't
see why i should have to use that three
minutes to correct the interpretation of
policy em-24 which was presented to the
committee as a binary choice if you
could bring em 24 up
it's in the on the front page of your
late papers and there's a key word
that's being missed out in fact two key
words being missed out of the
presentation
because if you see it's an either or
there
in part two
three lines down it says site on
premises are inherently unsuitable
this isn't a binary choice between a
marketing campaign or viability it's if
the site is inherently unsuitable
thank you
good morning members of the goats
afternoon i guess
your officers maintain their position in
reporting to you today which is what you
might expect them to do
but they like you saw this site for the
first time last week and we're only then
truly able to understand its constraints
and opportunities
i hope that your site visit convinced
you that we can build houses here that
has an employment site its realistic
prospects for development are zero as
they have been for the last 20 years
because it's inherently unsuitable
please take a positive decision today by
approving this application and do not
consign it to the depths of a
meaningless purposeless and completely
ineffective allocation for an employment
use in a planning policy documents
document which will do nothing but
gather another 20 years of planning dust
there are still matters in your offices
report which require emphasis on
clarification for example one third of
the dwellings which would be delivered
by this application are not within the
allocated employment site
the site access proposed in this
application to serve the residential
development has the approval of suffolk
county council's highway authority
it too does not form part of the
employment allocation
your officer's access solution is a new
access road which would be driven
through from lady lane into the existing
haulage yard turned through 90 degrees
reach an acoustic bun which they
previously have said was necessary to
separate that hauling yard from the site
below
and then drop the carriageway some three
meters in height before turning another
90 degrees so that can deliver the
employment land which we say is not
viable or is inherently unsuitable and
of course we now see that the viability
update confirms that b1 officers would
not be viable
however b2 and b8 is still viable your
officers claim and 90
net 90 net of the site is capable of
being delivered is that realistic
what allowance has been made in the
viability assessment for the
extraordinary road construction costs of
your officer scheme and would that
really result in a 90 percent night
sutton at site area
what account has taken the viability
mass of the employment land lost from
the pallets yard site for the e-road
land take
nothing is allowed for demolition and
site clearance you stood on almost an
acre of concrete what about the two
major steel pipes crossing through the
middle of the site they've been
accounted for in the residential scheme
in terms of the indicative layout
what form of noise attenuation would be
required along the boundaries to all the
properties until along oldham road a
three meter high acoustic fence three
meter high earthbound
where is the cost analysis associated
with these major infrastructure
essentials your viability update is
inadequate for the purpose
in any case our case is that the site is
inherently unsuitable
finally in any event is this the right
location for warehousing and
distribution or general industrial uses
for an existing hat for an existing site
with housing on three sides
as an employment allocation it has been
and will continue to be a white element
elephant
recently this council has had the
experience of an employment land just up
the road in hadley being donated to it
because the landowner could make sense
of a viable development scheme
the council's own former office building
also and hadley was proven to be in
non-viable employment use what more do
we need to confirm the position
contrast that with the application
before you today which delivers housing
which we also say is being
under-supplied and hadley as evidence in
the thorough housing needs assessments
are submitted with the application and
incidentally as uncontested by your
officers
in summary i appreciate that this is a
difficult site with a number of
constraints but none that has sustained
a technical objection from any of your
consultees
it is also a site full of opportunity
and i urge you to take that today with a
positive decision
thank you thank you
any questions for the agent
thanks for the beer
um
yes i understand your
desire to put houses on the site
have you
over the years or have you tried to
market it for i think our policy says
for up to two years to see if there is
any interest
um and i appreciate you say that the
site
isn't uh suitable there's houses on
three sides and what have you and i i
think i can most likely agree with you
on that one but um if you can just
answer whether you've done any um
going out to see if there's any interest
from another organization thank you
there's been no marketing campaign
undertaken because such would be
pointless and ineffective
okay
well we have no ward numbers present um
so that being the case i'll now open it
up
that's right chad i'm just going to ask
oh
yeah you said it would be pointless
but
had this been conducted a couple of
years ago then you would have been able
to say categorically and we would then
have a perhaps have a different view on
the site than just saying well it's not
worth doing
um i've been in commercial agency over
the past three or four decades
and there'll always be inquiries out
there
and you may get a telephone call but
they never develop into anything where
you have a site that's in this condition
it's
a major exercise to develop the
infrastructure to bring that forward so
immediately you're back into the terms
of viability
why go through the marketing exercise
when you know
that it's not going to be delivered it
can't be delivered it's not economic to
deliver it
i love okay
right
come on we have no ward members so i'll
open it up for debate who would like to
make casaba come on um i have every
sympathy for the applicant on this site
but we are slightly constrained by our
own policy on this
and um i i think had they come forward
with the marketing exercise in the last
20 years which has been empty
then we would not be in a position where
we're constrained by policy
um
and i'm very conscious of the fact that
you know we have other sites that come
forward and we have
the same thing so i think as a council
we have to be consistent is a policy
that we've adopted
the only thing i would maybe suggest is
that within within our power it could be
that we could reduce the time required
for the uh marketing campaign to be
taken
and then they can come back
with that
so we could then
approve with consistency that they've
tried
i i'm sorry i don't agree with the
applicant to say
it's never come forward you know it's
not viable because that's not the case
so many sites might not be viable from
his experience but someone else might
come forward and again
it's down to price
so obviously you're there as trying to
get the highest price for your uh client
um but the client needs to be
fairly um
realistic that he sits on an employment
side so the value of that employment
side would be less if his aspiration is
to actually get a higher value because
he gets planning permission that's fine
if he but he needs to take the risk of
actually bringing forward a policy for
us to be able to accept and i think at
the moment
um to say that it's not viable um i
think is is not correct because we
haven't seen the evidence to say that
and that's where i sit
what is the time scale
is it 24 months
it's not defined in the policy there is
an spd but ultimately if you're
following the policy which is obviously
the the important part um it is talking
about the sustained campaign that is uh
agreed and undertaken at a realistic
asking price so i mean it it's it's open
to discussion effectively
it's answering your question to a
certain extent isn't it
it need not necessarily be two years
time scale yeah very good thank you
councillor parker please
um yeah well i i actually
i concur wholeheartedly with councillor
barrett actually i i really want to
support this application but um
i genuinely do but our hands are tied um
but i i would just like some um comment
from the officer if it's possible um uh
the uh the applicant mentioned that um
our policy em 24 um was was in some way
not not deficient but that it hadn't
been explained good enough to us and i
think stephen i think i saw you reaching
for your button at the time sort of
thing that have you got any comment to
make on that
sorry that that may well have been
instinctual um but it it's a policy in
force it's a policy that we would
consider to be up to date i had a a
brief read of the the applicant's
commentary on that that they feel that
things have changed on the ground that
would render that policy out of date i
think officers disagree
there is also of course this this
interesting point that as a council
we've already looked at this site and
considered to be
suitable for employment uses hence it's
been presented for examination
which is going on on right now and
obviously that will run its course but
um that
that allocation clearly has been
reviewed it's even been altered as the
case officer pointed out
to account for change
but it still remains the case that we
consider this to be a suitable site um
the
council's um viability
expert considers uh
there to be um a viable option there for
some employment use um and quite simply
members you've got a policy there this
is in breach of the policy there's harm
to the plan it's an up-to-date plan we
would say um ordinarily you would not
grant planning permission for this on
this
material considerations were weighty
enough to indicate that you should
depart from the plan it's it's really
quite a simple exercise actually
thank you mr chairman well i don't want
to agree with counselor barrett on this
pattern at all
because
whilst i understand it is policy
uh i accept that
common sense which i know we can't take
into consideration in planning common
sense tells us when you stood in the
middle of that site
with all those houses on three sides
that it was not the ideal place for
industrial use
in today's age
it may have been in the past
i come from village where we had
two three factories on the go they've
all gone and then they've been replaced
with housing
one stood empty for over 20 years
because the powers that be the planned
department insisted that was kept for
industrial use it never got looked at
again and we eventually got hoses on it
but um
it is one of those situations where
the policy states that um they they
should go down the road of trying to
market it i can understand why they
haven't
and i can also understand that we we
should be able to treat this on its
merits and not put them through this
because i quite believe and i would hope
that if you went down that road you'd
only make it one year that in 12 months
time they'd come back there'd be no
interest in it because it's just not the
right place to have articulated larry's
encouraged to go in the center of hadley
there
it's nothing is good in its favor in my
opinion and i think that we should um
approve
a housing thank you
councillor buzzfeed
yeah um
i don't actually like it for either of
them could be honest i think
as an employment site
it shouldn't be industrial because they
if you put anything on there that is
similar to the what's on lady lane it'll
be
detrimental to the houses that are below
if you put the hat 45 houses on that
could be the detriment to the industry
that's above
in terms it could impact on their
ability to operate in future there's
already noise and smells odors that
emulate from the site
so
i don't think 45 houses on there
either is suitable having said that
i think if either scheme uh if if it was
going to be employment it would need to
be
um category e so kind of offices or
something light so you wouldn't be
getting hgvs on there you'd be getting
vans etc but or if it's houses i think
there's too many 45 i think it feels a
road that ran straight down the middle
and you had houses on either side
so you kept the houses away from the
industrial site
then i think that might be acceptable
but i'm not keen on 45 at the moment
casey mclaren
thank you chair
sorry
um
well having as we did a site visit
the site is really not very attractive
and um
i think
if we
remind it to go with the recommendation
of the officer
then what
it's an eyesore in hadley
and i understand there was no objection
from hadley town council or anybody i
think i remember that i'm speaking to
somebody
and
it's we're sort of in a dead end at the
moment aren't we where
we're being offered a solution
um whether that's flawed or not is
beside the point
but what is there at the moment is just
not acceptable to the residents of
hadley
thank you
thank you parker
yeah thank you i don't disagree um with
what you're saying there council
mccarran but but i'm just looking
through the report here and actually
it's not absolutely clear-cut what
hadley council um seem to think it looks
as though they supported this maybe on a
technicality um and unfortunately we
haven't got the ward members here to
sort of although they were on the site
visit so um
what whatever that might be but but i i
have some sympathy with what you're
saying councilman karen you know we can
sit there for another year and then what
but equally as councillor busby said
earlier um with with with due respect
the applicant may say that it's not
worth his while um uh doing this but
that means that we haven't got the
evidence in front of us to make that
decision um so
as much as i want to agree with council
of beer i'm afraid if we if we go
against policy here we've got to go
against policy everywhere else as well
so
for me
you know it's um it's a technicality and
at the moment i've i've got to go with
the officer's recommendation i'm not
making that proposal until we've heard
for the debate um mr chairman well i can
do
and tell you i will make that a proposal
i'll make that a proposal chairman if i
if i can i'll propose
with the officer's recommendation have
you a secondary
council jameson
do you want to say anything or
only that i agree with cancer department
if we
go against policy at the drop of a hat
without no evidence on the country then
this council park says we could go
against all the policies and as we've
just spent two years
doing the joint local plan i mean that
would be
thank you
if i could um maybe just
offer an amendment to councillor
parker's proposal
and that we reduce
the marketing time
required on em
as part of the proposal as part of the
refusal
can we do that
i mean
no
to be honest
we've got the reasons for refusal but i
think the applicant an agent is here in
the room they're listening to what
you're saying and i think that um
they do of course have a right of appeal
but if they wanted to come back and talk
talk this through um then obviously
we're willing to have that conversation
as a committee after the give a steer
i'm sorry can we give a steer oh i i
think you are right right now in effect
because what i would i mean bear in mind
that and i take you know council
mclaren's point and
this is a very
it's a poor sight to leave there and
it's been in poor condition
um for a long while
i don't want to prolong the thing i
think what i'm conscious of and um
as i say if it wasn't for policy i would
be voting for it i think it's quite a
nice little scheme in the centre of
hadley but on a policy issue and i'm
very conscious of the fact we have other
sites that we have this same issue on in
sudbury and other sites where people are
bringing forward employment sites and
wanting to put this on i think if we do
this and we don't keep our own policy
then we are in a danger of just and i
think council park has brought it up
so i i would say that the steer that i
would like to give the planning officers
is that we give them a 75 discount
six months
because by the time we got this through
and everything else done you're there so
i mean i think it would give us a lot of
ease yeah if this came back in six
months time having had the marketing
exercise i think all counselors here
with a clear conscience we could
probably and i get the feeling we would
be happy to accept the proposal before
us but at the moment
with the um with the policy position
that we've got bearing in mind we have
other sensitive sites in the district
which have this issue i think we need to
be firm on this one
yeah thank you mr chairman i'm
absolutely in agreement with our fellow
councillors
here on this application it's
it's neither one or the other and um
i think the officer has
proceeded to give us the
various reasons for it and i would not
like to go against that officer's
decision as it stands whether it's for
employment or for housing i think
as councillor barrett has said
get to a position where we could
actually uh
identify where we could go with this
rather than uh rather than go around the
house
i'm sorry but
i i won't go against the officer's
recommendation it is policy on other
sites that we've we've dealt with and
we've got to stick to it thank you thank
you
councilman
well i don't think we should think that
we've got to fill every square inch of
every town with housing or employment
sites
we have got a biodiversity
strategy which is aimed to put in
uh land that is not being built on
and i think this would have been an
ideal site for that so
we tend to be obsessed with having to
fill in everything with one or the other
and i don't think we should
can i ask officers a question quick
question um if we do have a marketing
exercise um how much weight does that
in terms of offsetting a policy decision
that will be firmed up even more because
in six months time there's a good chance
the joint local plan will be in place
well and and that's the worry obviously
you you take a decision based on the
prevailing
policy context at the time um i think as
i said if there's a move to
go with the officer's recommendation
then it would be a refusal um
we're absent any
legal of legal advisor here today but i
would imagine that as part of the
resolution you could
indicate
how you could see a marketing exercise
carried out however i would urge against
that because one i think six months is
too short two we don't have
relevant expertise or officer input from
the economic development team
so i think
i'm getting very loud and clear that um
some of the members would like some
pragmatic discussion as ever officers
are open to that um and that i think
should be treated as a separate exercise
i think ultimately you've got a
recommendation before you and that's
that's the one that you you ought to
take and then of course if if the
applicants would like to go down that
first limb of the current policy as it
sits they can have that conversation
with um
the the relevant team
any more comments
go to parents do you wish to say
something wrong
i would be very disappointed if the
officers then came and then what
enforced a full 24 months
because in the moment
that's
you know
we really don't want to see that
and i'd rather put it in some sort of
firm but firm up that we don't have a 24
month
as part and i'm sure we can do that
decision takers i just think that's
that's probably not a wise choice today
i think you have a recommendation to
take and you've clearly signaled that
you would like pragmatic discussions to
be undertaken in respect of the length
and breadth of any marketing campaign
and that should be i think probably left
to the officers to consider
so mr chairman we could put forward an
amendment to say
um that if councillor parker accepted it
that we want to give them 12 months not
two years
to do a marketing review
and and sorry i've been um spinning
multiple plates just looking at the spd
it's actually it is 12 months it's the
minimum marketing campaign it's not
actually 24. so you've already got 50
discounts
you can't do that it has to be a
if you make a specific period time
period imagine going back the last 12
months that would have been absolutely
pointless we wouldn't have got any
response whatsoever the next 12 months
might be different who knows
i think it should be a suitable
term which is 12 months perhaps i think
i think the point is
i think we are trying to do policy
compliant
most of us in a pragmatic way would
approve this
sorry
i'm locked on now
no
no i've just been oh i have it's come
back
you already might come in
so as as the proposer i think what our
officer has just told us is that what we
want we've already got
in which case uh can we can we move on
yes we'll go to a vote
and this is to accept the officer's
recommendation
thank you chair members that vote is now
in progress in your app
um
councillor bosby would you like me to
take your vote oh no you don't thank you
thank you members chair that's 10 votes
for refusal so that's unanimous that's
an answer
before we leave this but perhaps it
might be worth talking to the cabinet
member for
planning we've just woken up over there
um in in terms of the fact that we we
have a
plan and part of the the joint local
plan is it's a designation of these
these areas for employment
um you know how
rigorously was was was that sort of
investigated when the joint level plan
was being put together because it seems
to me it wasn't a great deal
and it just it just flipped over from
from what was an existing plan
yes am i
am i allowed to answer yes well i mean
i'll give the sort of
the standard archer if you like and that
is that the joint local plan was
supported by an enormous amount of
evidence
um
with regard to the assessment of this
particular site i could look into it for
you i mean i i don't know what evidence
was presented for this particular site
well it's just
you know it just rings of just having
been run continued on and and nothing
done about it and
then therefore that makes you wonder
about one or two other sites as well but
but
we'll just stick with this one first if
we may
thank you probably to look into that
thank you very much we will move on to
the next item
which
there's
the land
at cobbling's farm
hadley
gc2005137
catherine are you set to give us a
presentation
thank you chair so this is an outline
application for
employment use on land at kobold's farm
it's proposed both class e and class b 2
and b 8 use
so hadley of c it sits outside of hadley
which is the town or main urban area
it's not allocated as employment land
class e
now allows for a variety of uses it's
you know it's quite generic employment
uses i think there is potential for it
to be offices but it as it's outline
only it doesn't
have to be solely office it can be
anything listed there so it could be
retail
um it can be obviously crash nursery
office and so on
so the key key issues today for this
application is i'll see again the status
of the adopted development plan
land use policy going forwards in the
emerging joint local plan
and there's quite a few landscape
ecology issues with fat bits in the
countryside
potentially highway and traffic
considerations
so this is a site
flashing in red adjacent
the site you've got kersey freight and
beeston's coaches as you'll probably
hopefully remember from site visits last
week
so again to just put it into wider
context as to where the site is it's
along the a-1071
outside of the built-up area boundary
for for hadley
over here on the
pointer on the left you've got wieder's
weavers meadow development which is
currently being brought forward which
does contain an element of employment
land and this site including the
employment
land is allocated
in the draft joint local plan
and over here is the obviously the
application site
so this is an illustrative layout
because the matter is outline permission
structural landscaping
um and with the access although the
access is just to use the existing one
this is just to show you how something
could look on the site
hopefully you'll remember that there's
an existing paddock up here which would
be for the class proposed for the class
e
potential uses
and then down here adjacent to the
existing
courtesy freight site is obviously
proposed um b2 and b8 use
so that just shows i'll see
hopefully up close
so
as you can see within the emerging draft
drink local plan the site is roughly
here i think
um
you've got the allocation
lao 28 the section within this part of
the red lines
is employment there's no allocation in
the emerging draft joint local plan for
the cobwebs farm or this section of land
so at the moment it would be bringing
forwards
employment site on existing agricultural
land contrary to to policy
in terms of constraints you've got a
public right-of-way that goes through
the site
and the actual proposal isn't going to
impact or divert the public right of way
the the site itself the proposal
separates the two areas
potentially of the classy and then the
b2v8 so the footpath would remain as it
is
in terms of other constraints the site
itself
isn't constrained however there are a
number of constraints
nearby particularly in terms of special
landscape area
triple s eyes nature reserves ancient
woodland known as wolves wood
over to the north on the opposite side
of the a-1071
and then obviously over here you've got
further woods s triple s eyes and a
nature reserve
so it just just shows you'll see the
status of two with a black one being the
site
other constraints there's a list of
building over here but it's obviously
not near the site so not to worry
um the access visit as you'll hopefully
remember there's an existing access
which is highways compliant highways
have no issue with the proposal in terms
of the use of this access as it's wide
enough and offers
plenty of visibility displays in both
directions
they're just associate you'll see me
access to and through the site again the
public right of way just in context
would go sorry go along here
so landscaping is one of considerations
hopefully you'll remember from a site
visit at the moment there's an existing
landscape fund to the front of a site
and it separates or see the site from
the a1071 and there's also one along
this boundary
there's proposals to enhance the
planting and retain as much of a
landscaping buffer as possible improving
on the omni bund
[Music]
so in terms of the recommendation from
officers is refusal due to the fact that
it's in countries like countryside
location and um against policy we've
also already got employment land
allocated elsewhere within um hadley
and the both the adopted local plan and
also the emerging joint local plan so
this is the weavers meadow site which
already has permission for employment
obviously next to the part of the built
up area boundary going forwards and in
much closer proximity to to hadley
itself in terms of sustainability
so this is the employment site as
adopted um
the start of what is known as weaver's
meadow
so just to reiterate
employment
see dwellings and the site over here
not allocated and
some way from the existing built up area
boundary with no footpath there is
obviously public footpath through the
fields there's no direct footpath
um along sort of the main road
these are just some images again
hopefully from visiting the site it's
it's clear where the where these were
taken so the access to the actual site
is here
and the site is this part and this part
so here you can see the existing bee
students um coaches depot to the front
of a site
and kind of behind obviously where these
coaches are is and around the back is
the cozy freight
this would be the site access as you can
see as highways don't have any objection
it's a fairly recent access with good
visibility on both sides
and this is taken as you're heading
towards hadley and the site so you've
mostly got open fields also you can't
see anything in the distance because of
a bund and it's just out of shot by
these trees
again just further images
so on the right you can see you've also
got the um the nature reserve in the
woods
so the recommendation is refusal um
considering it's contrary to policy
as it's in the country so countryside
location and isn't an allocated
employment site
thank you very much catherine
are there any
questions
yeah thank you mr chairman just um
clarification of the previous
application i didn't
i might have
gone deaf but i didn't hear what the uh
outcome was what the vote was
mclaren
thank you chair
catherine just one question
um
you're mindless to refuse this so how
did beeston's and kersey freight get
approval for their site which is of
course adjacent to this application
um
i can't expressly say other than um
i either went to committee and was
considered acceptable or potentially
policy at the time
and may have given its use leaned
towards it
yeah it would appear to be quite a dated
permission i don't know whether there
are anyone here in the room that was
that was
uh
present when that decision was taken but
i dare say that
as a decision of its time
there would have been a different policy
context um certainly in terms of it
would i would imagine have predated the
framework or certainly the current
iteration um
and of course it would have turned on
its own facts i wouldn't necessarily say
to you that because there is an approval
there and an extent use that that should
necessarily indicate that this is a an
approval on its merits and clearly it's
been tested on its merits against the
current
plan and other material considerations
sure
the opposite
no
you're using the other hand david that's
why i couldn't see you
i mean there's two parts to that the
first one the the beeston's coaches
think they've been their donkeys haven't
they but we extended that site fairly
recently and insisted on on an improved
access
so it was extended
yeah about
well it's as long ago as that
so we have taken it from what was an
historic site
to
an enlarged employment side
originally it was a county council farm
uh and they sold the land to
to beeston's to put their bus depot
there provided that bee stones could get
planning permission to put houses on
their existing site in the middle of
hadley okay that's why i didn't hand it
it was the land swap effectively
i wonder where this is
right any other questions
no if not we'll move on there are no
representatives from the town council no
objective no supporter
so mr short you're on again
thank you chair the the extension to the
coldwell farm employment side proposed
in this application you should see is a
completely logical and well-founded
planning decision
the land could make a meaningful
contribution towards hadley's job
prospects when recent decisions have
seen the council lose allocated
employment land and premises
successively and thus local hadley job
opportunities
the cobbles farm site is discreet in the
landscape and virtually invisible in the
locality
the structural landscaping that forms
part of this application seeks to build
upon what has already been established
as you saw on your site visit
in doing so it is also possible to
enhance biodiversity at the same time
and i know catherine's mention of the
the
ecological the rsp reserve and so on but
you also know that the rsbp rspb were
consulted and did not object
on that site visit you saw it firsthand
and the stark difference between the two
sites the tired inaccessible site at
lady lane with its significant
constraints to viable employment
development and by contrast the
significant opportunity that approving
this site of kabul's farm for employment
purposes would bring
the cobbles farmland is deliverable and
part of the wider site is already in
very active employment use
cozy freight for example currently
employs 99 people
and is expanding and needs more space
your office's report dismisses the
interest expressed to date and securing
accommodation on on this side why
because it's only five or six and it's
likely to stifle the bringing forward of
other allocations in hadley
and on that particular point i note that
the allocation in hadley now weaver's
meadow was itself reduced from five and
a half hectares to 0.9 hectares on the
basis that the owner of the land
said it was not viable
and i think that's the land that was
gifted to the council
i will close by urging you to recognize
the realistic development deliverable
opportunity that exists in approving
this application
has anyone any questions
thank you
i don't know what interest you've had in
the sites that there's two kind of sites
there isn't there would you be would you
be intending to build them out without
interest coming forward or would you do
it on a piecemeal basis
i think you you had the advantage of the
site visit and you'll see that the major
infrastructure to this site the key to
it is always access the major
infrastructure is there
and the condition that came about
that required that access when the
freight yard was extended next to
beeson's
cost an absolute fortune that
infrastructure was put in so now
looking for the return on that
investment and you saw that within the
contained landscape area
there is a parcel of land that is
perfectly capable of development
drainage too can be extended um so it's
it's a it's a short
hop step skipping a job to do it but
you're right there wouldn't be six
thousand square meters of speculative
build hanging around for someone um as a
result of a very effective marketing
campaign
um i think it will be done on a phased
basis and it will respond to interest
and for example
you will know because i presented it
in the submission there are five who
already want floor space but the biggest
need currently is because he's freight
who need to relocate an outdated
outmoded office building on the lady
lane industrial estate to their yacht
and i was the app i was the um
agent for the uh application in long
vessels
um i wasn't the agent for the extension
for kersey's freight but their origins
are both based on the same thing the
desire to get traffic heavy goods
vehicle traffic be their buses or hgbs
conventional
out of hadley town and hadley town
center and this was deemed to be the
best location for it
thank you
no thank you very much in that case
we'll throw it open to debate anybody
like to kick off
thank you thank you councilman you're
one and i'll go again and i think uh
picking up that last point
employment sites are aren't always best
cited around housing
you know we we don't want the uh large
hgvs etc going through our towns and a
site like this one
is probably suitable for it i actually
quite like it as a site
um
for
extension
which is what it would be the site is
already there it would be extended i
know we've got issues with what it's
designated but
i've got an issue i've got a
a place in chattishan which is a chair
which is a farm which has got continued
expansion on it and it drives the
neighbors mad
it shouldn't be an employment site it's
an agricultural side but
it's in the countryside it's it keeps
getting extended i can't see the
difference between
this one
and the one that's in chaddisha if you
can extend an existing site why can't
they extend this one
to me it looks like it's a good site for
the kind of extension that they're
talking about
i would restrict the
the usage to
e
at the front and b at the back i
wouldn't want to see it as totally or b
any other comments
thank you
thank you chair um i don't want to
violate
but
um i do feel that the access there is
very good and your point was very good
over there and i do think it um i would
i would approve it not disapprove it
thank you
hey sir parker
um
i
don't disagree with what counselor says
except that we're in exactly the same
position as we were previously weren't
we um we we have a policy um
and and you know it's perfectly
reasonable if we consider that there are
if the benefits outweigh uh the policies
there's no reason why we can't um why we
can't go against the officer
recommendation but we've just in in the
last application we've just talked about
consistency
and if so if we're consistent in that
discussion uh then we um surely we have
to go with officer's recommendation on
this as well
board are you working i i take on board
council parker's point of consistency
but i think this is a different type of
consistency
so this is this is a new um this is not
an existing pot not existing use this is
a new use
on the greenfield site
so you could argue that uh
that is a no there's no
um
precedent being set beforehand because
it's obviously a new decision for us and
it's more about the
um
built-up area boundary that we're going
into but i'm always thinking goes back
to council at busby's point
do are we better putting an industrial
site on a built up area boundary next to
housing or in the open countryside next
to an existing industrial site well i
think most people would go it's best to
put it where we you've got an industrial
site so i i don't think um i take cancer
father's point and as well meant and i
think it's it's it's accurate but i
think it is different
any other questions
can i make the comment that if you put
some industrial units here it takes a
little bit of the pressure off trying to
market the one near the town doesn't it
so you have to bear that in mind as well
um
ryan so no more comments
sorry guys
i will come back and i'll
i will dig my feet in um on this um if i
if i may i might get thrown down that's
that's absolutely fine but um
2.2 for me is absolutely safe against
page 149 it is believed to be a
speculative application as the applicant
has not identified any occupiers which
are currently lined up for this site and
has not associated the proposal with
adjacent audit activity so there is i
think there's a difference uh maybe
that's not entirely what we heard um
from um from the agent there but if 2.2
is is correct again to my mind it comes
back to evidence base um so whilst i
absolutely agree with sentiment and
whilst i do
in in theory whilst i i support what my
colleagues are saying again we don't
have the evidence do we to go against
policy
so
where is the overwhelming
um benefit to the to the district to go
against policy here would be would just
be the point i would make
cautiously
character jokes
thank you sir um yeah i agree with
councillor parker um only we're going
against policy if we agree this but
we're also encouraging people to drive
to work
and we're starting a ribbon
developments along the a-1071 how long
before
we end up with the whole
road
along their developments
thank you
can i suppose
well in a way i'd be quite good if we
could imagine the success we could
making out of all those employment sites
if we have hundreds of thousands of jobs
if we made it totally written
development but i mean maybe we should
be looking at altering
the policy
stephen
again
any other sorry i was expecting a
response
they weren't getting one
counselor
thanks to the baron you wanted to
comment again
well i'm
we're going around the houses here
someone's got us
i actually um
i'm actually happy to propose that we
approve the planning application on the
basis that the
uh
that it actually has more benefit
uh than harm in terms of the employment
prospects
in terms of
we have lost a number of uh businesses
locally
and in baby district most businesses are
grow organically
and grow from one building to another
and at the moment we have a massive
shortage of buildings that they can go
into
and i think there is an element there
where speculative um
employment development of this nature
will help
retain
our existing employers into such a
site
we are very limited there is nothing in
sudbury
there's very limited in
uh suitable sites and this is where it's
key it's suitable sites and it goes back
to the access and keeping the vehicles
out of
out of the town center so i actually do
feel that this site has merit
and i would propose that
i haven't got a second
just policy points as well because if
you're
you appear to be going down the line of
so um
first and foremost i think just to pick
up on some of the points raised
um this as far as i'm aware is not being
badged as an expansion of kersey freight
this is an outline application which
proposes a mix of uses
and quite a sizable proportion of which
is classy and then possibly b2 there may
be no b8 that comes forward
on the policy side and policy cs2 really
is the linchpin here you're looking for
exceptional circumstances and a proven
justifiable need for this development
and officers don't think that
neither of those two
limbs of that policy test are satisfied
so this is in effect again a departure
from the plan
and you're looking at whether the
benefits here are sufficiently weighty
to to merit to departure from the plan i
think council jameson has made a good
point in that some of these uses are
clearly going to generate quite a lot of
jobs which on the one hand is very good
but we're in a location here where
ultimately people will drive this is not
somewhere where anyone will cycle to
work they will certainly not walk to
work this is a busy road
and and this is precisely why the
policies are framed in the way that they
are to direct development to suitable
and sustainable locations and there is
no guarantee that this will be a hgv
site
so i just need to make that clear and if
you want to keep pressing on that's fine
but we will need some reasons
well i think i've given the reasons i
think the vantages way because we are
desperately short of employment land in
baber district if you can
in the western area of baby have you got
any land you've got allocated for
potential development i don't you've got
any because i haven't seen it in the
local plan
and there are the ones that have got um
which is children um
well children woods is not coming for
but you've also got churchfoot road
which is under pressure anyway and your
own local plan revised has
actually caused that to go white and not
as employment land so you clearly don't
think there is much there so i think you
need to really look at that as well if
we're taking those
you know into the context
to counsel about it
absolutely sure we know exactly what
we're voting on
i i think in these circumstances um
and
in the absence of um mr duprey or any of
our other
legal advisers
we know from
painful experience that it's challenging
when you
propose a recommendation as contrary to
what officers have put to you
i would suggest that
we record a minded two
recommendations so that we can go away
and craft the reasons for you and come
back and we can we can ultimately vote
on those because um
in the absence of of of clear and
detailed reasons at this point i fully
take you know you've been very
articulate in the way that you've gone
about things counsel about but
it does leave us open to risk and i
would like us to go away and take we can
come back
so we so you would be voted affected to
record that what you're minded to do and
instruct officers i think to go away
um and uh
and crafts and reasons for you to come
back and vote on with with um any
relevance and related risk assessment
can we have that read out so we know
exactly where we were
or is that it
that that was that was my suggestion um
to to to members that i'm people
exposing and
please
sorry what are we voting on because i
think mr stroud is suggesting that we go
away that he goes away and comes up with
some admirable reasons and all the rest
of it and conditions and then we vote
so all we're voting on here will be to
defer something for mr stroud to go away
and look at it that's right that's fine
don't think that's been made clear
yes i think that
i'll let the chief playing
deal with that point
uh thanks steve um yeah i mean i think
just for clarity what i would suggest
you're doing here and what i would
suggest is a prudent course of action
given that we have
been judicially reviewed over
our failure to
successfully apply cs2 to industrial uh
developments
and not
not a million years ago either
that what officers are the members take
a minded to two resolution on whatever
it is they want to do to grant
permission or otherwise
and that officers are instructed to
review the requirements of
cs2 and the risk issues that might arise
from granting permission and as
appropriate
recommend conditions or reasons that may
be relevant to that
[Applause]
so mr chairman that would come back to
us as a committee to
vote on yes
are you happy with that
what time frame are we talking about are
you talking about coming back about
opposite or are we talking about
the next planning commitment or next
year or more
i may i mean usually you can hardly walk
out the door or committee and then
instantly push somebody through the
governance team to close for the next
agenda so i would i would be inclined to
think this is going to be towards the
back end of september that you will see
this as my instinct here because we've
obviously got to do a little bit of work
and given the lead time for committee
you know i i think
you're looking back into september as
early october as a timing my instinct
okay
have you have you
thank you chair members that vote has
been amended in mod garb and is now in
progress
um
thank you members chair that's six votes
four and four go votes against that is
carried so that's 64 and that's carrie
okay thank you very much
we have one more very small item and i
think a number of people would like a
lube break
[Music]
thank you
um dc 20 05 136 nope
dc 2102 5777
cali street depot
hiking my hadley
catherine would you now like to make a
presentation
thank you chair
this is an application for
demolition of the existing
building and erection or siting of free
storage containers
it's for the depot in hadley that we own
so it's brought before members because
it's council-owned land
um
the reason it's before members is ever
so slightly complicated um
because they wish to demolish a building
within the conservation area there's um
depending on the size of building you
can eat it and whether it constitutes
development depends on whether we'll see
it needs prior notification or
permission
it was deemed to be
over the the standard cubic size so it
required permission and therefore
obviously as it was council owned land
it's before members so it's purely
really because the building was
is considered large under permitted
development rights and demolition but
it's before us rather than any other
reason
so this is an aerial map of the site
i'll try and
so i'll see
this is the depot building here site
access
skate parking and playground
here obviously you've got residential
units along here and along here
hadley high street is further down here
just to make it obviously slightly more
clear where it is in the wider context
so it's up here
this is the high street this is a
magdalen car park within hadley
now this is a site location plan and
this is a building
just about see if it's um proposed to be
demolished
the constraints it's in as i've
mentioned earlier it's in the
conservation area and therefore hence
needs permission due to the demolition
aspect
and as its council and that's why it's
here before members today there are no
other constraints as we'll see some
listed buildings
over here the start of a high street but
they're not affected by the proposal in
any way
just an existing block plan so this is a
building proposed to be demolished it's
currently used for storage
it's the only kind of base within hadley
that workers ground workers can store
their their equipment and such
and they're proposing to put free
storage containers on site one is to be
a welfare unit
as there is no other
um you know council owned points within
baber specifically for for you know
toilet or anything like that for
grounds workers to access and then these
two containers would be for storage
the existing building is in quite a bad
state of repair which is why they're
considered it's best to knock it down
and replace it with storage containers
um
the benefit of storage containers as
opposed to an actual building and they
can be considered as
chattels and therefore actually they can
be easily removed if and when the site
is no longer required
in the future
so
quite straightforward it's
recommendation for approval
with any of the kid additions that are
set out in the committee report
thank you catherine any questions for
the officer
the rights come up i can see council
jameson
just one um the recommendation says
operating hours what
are the operating hours do you recommend
him
um it's proposed
that i've also i've spoken with john
buckingham who's head of the
team operations and hours of work or
access to the site would be required
between half seven in the morning
and four thirty
week days with occasional weekend um
for call outs so that wouldn't be
permanently used at weekends but if
there was a call out grounds operation
needed then they may need access
to to the storage equipment and also um
just to clarify there's no proposal for
storage
on-site
outside of storage containers so the
containers will be used for all storage
there won't be anything left out on site
there won't be any waste
building up on the area though but it's
purely for you know the use of the
storage containers and i can condition
that there's no outside storage
to ensure that nothing is is put on on
the site
thank you mr chairman can i
ask you what
the storage facilities are for what
what are they storing there
various um equipment for their grounds
works
and call out operations that the baba
communities team offer
the fact that you've got three storage
containers there so what's the
likelihood of them
coming back for more than
i mean obviously the application has
accessed on its own merit so if more
were to potentially come in then
you could assess it then
one of the storage units is a welfare
unit so we'll have a toilet and
obviously facilities there for them to
potentially make cup of tea
in between jobs and obviously use a
facility so it's only two
storage containers for the purpose of
storing equipment and so on
um but there is nothing to stop them
coming
potentially coming back or putting more
on however we could potentially
condition it
to say that you know
the storage containers as approved are
to be the only ones on the site
i'll move the officer's recommendation
then there'll be no story
making
wait till we get into the debate i'm
very very keen for you to do so but
until until we finished
everybody asking their questions
we're still asking questions so so
don't let them view it people then i
think you'll find it much easier
counselor
you wanted to yeah just just a quick
question really um
i agree with the use of the of the
containers because they're very easy to
make secure
so vandals and thieves and things can't
get it what's often valuable
groundskeeping equipment
presumably they will be green rather
than have ever given or something
written on the side of them i mean come
straight from felix today
sorry
um i presume they would i don't think
there's been any anything to state what
what color they would be but i can i can
thank thank you chair um just to ask um
the plans for removing
what is there at the moment
um when is it likely to happen will it
disrupt the residents will there be a
plan for that living next door against
this house i remember when the building
next to it was being taken down thank
you
i i couldn't say when they would be
proposing to see remove it my
understanding is
the sooner the better um it would
obviously benefit them we can
condition and ask for
i say a construction management plan but
the equivalent for for demolition so
that you know we can control the hours
of demolition ensure there's no
burning on site everything is removed
off site so that can be part of the
conditions
thank you very much
there are no public speakers we have no
town council or objector supporter
we have no
agent we have no ward members so we can
move in debate
thanks for here
you're anticipated
thank you very much i'll second the
office council barrett seconded any more
questions in the debate
no fine thank you we will take a vote
thank you very much
thank
you members of the boat is in progress
thank you members chair that's 10 votes
that's unanimous
decision
thank you for your patience everyone
the um meeting is scheduled for the 25th
of august
and with a bit of luck we might be
talking about a chocolate bag
chocolate factory
i'd go to meeting clothes
you